hey everyone i'm quincy coming to you
from
dallas texas uh united states of america
i am thrilled to be here to
open lockdown conf and we have some
amazing
interviews uh some amazing panels with
some
really incredible developers from around
the world today
we are also going to be delving into
four different topics that i think are
very near and dear
to all of our hearts these days
continuing
working from home effectively finding a
job
during this pandemic this unprecedented
change
in lifestyle for pretty much everybody
around the world
this is massive economic shock
and finding freelance opportunities and
we're going to find that there are many
many opportunities out there even in
the tragedy uh the human tragedy in the
chaos
of this pandemic so
first i would love to introduce fuzzil
he is uh the co-founder
of hashnote which is an amazing
developer community where you can go you
can configure your
developer your dev blog you can have a
blog running right on your website
uh on your own domain you can set it up
really quickly you can customize it it's
really powerful tool
and just so just check out hashtag if
you haven't i created the astronaut blog
a while back
i think it's amazing uh and then
of course he's going to be with me the
entire time co-em seeing
fielding questions from the audience
from both twitter and from
our live chat as a spam counter measure
and also to support the free code
non-profit i'll just be completely
candid about that uh we are
limiting the chatting on the youtube
video uh to people
who are willing to become members on
youtube
uh i think it's it scales with which
city you're in so
if you're in india i think it's like the
equivalent to us dollars i think in the
us it's closer to five dollars
i'm not sure what it is in other cities
but those are the two prices i've heard
um and this money goes to funding free
code camp
uh which is creating lots of free
learning resources for people around the
world
so uh first i'd like to introduce angie
jones
she is a quality assurance
engineer expert she's been doing this
for a long time
she is a developer evangelist at
appletools and she's also the director
of the test automation u
learning resource i strongly recommend
you check her out follow her on twitter
her information should be in the
description as with all the other
uh panelists today in the description
down below you can just scroll down you
can just command click
or control click open up all those
awesome people on twitter follow them
there i follow all of them they're all
super
interesting on twitter uh so thank you
very much for joining us angie
um next emma bostian
coming to us from carl's room uh in
germany
i hope i pronounced that correctly uh
thanks
um she is a uh
prolific developer and podcaster
you may have heard the ladybug podcast
uh i strongly recommend following her on
twitter as well
uh she is constantly doing exciting
things
and then of course dalwah shaw
uh the founder of classcentral.com which
you may very well have used in the past
month
they've been growing very rapidly uh
because they have
indexed i don't know
thousands maybe a hundred thousand
reviews at this point
of different free online courses and in
paid online courses like udemy courses
and stuff
it's a great place to find courses to
figure out
what how you want to learn
what kind of resources you want to use
which universities
are putting out the best courses so it's
a great way to just find the best
courses
to learn so welcome everybody
thank you quincy it's a pleasure to
co-host
yes thank you yeah great to be here
all right so first uh i think we should
just
open it up this is the topic of this
first panel
is learning the code during the pandemic
uh during the in the age of social
distancing
i think the first thing that's going to
be on pretty much everybody's mind is
you know how should they best
use in just general terms how should
they best use this block of time
that fate has handed them uh assuming
that like activities that used to occupy
a lot of their their free time are now
just
spent sitting at home uh how how should
they best use that
uh in your opinion and we'll go ahead
and start with angie what are your
thoughts on that
yeah let me let me start off by saying
that you know this is a
trying time for everyone so
um personally i've been you know having
ups and downs as far as my moods and
um the time this this time that we feel
we have
available some days it's not it's just a
myth right
um it feels like i have this extra time
um
but you know i have i still have my job
to do
um if you have kids at home that's
additional work as well
and if you're just not feeling up to it
you're just not feeling up to it and i
think that that's okay
so i just want to preface anything i say
with that all right
for me i love learning new things
i'm a teacher at heart as well so i'm
trying to produce lots of content for
people who are
at home and want to level up during this
time
as far as my own learning my own
productivity
i i use my updates right
so the days that i am feeling good and
i'm feeling productive
and i'm kind of tuning out the news or
the days that i'm able to
delve into all of the things that are
out there there's so much content
free code camp plenty of content there
just all over the web there's all of
these courses and things like that
um that you can take a lot of them for
free
so that that's my recommendation like
find what what's the skill that you want
to learn don't try to learn like all the
things during this time
but pick like one or two things that you
would like to master during this time
and find the
resources to do so
okay awesome thank you for that
comprehensive insightful answer
angie and and i just want to echo what
angie said it's totally fine during this
unprecedented time especially if you
have family members who are sick
or if you're concerned that you yourself
have become sick uh
with kava 19 or if you have other
medical issues and you're just
anxious about not being able to go to
the hospital like normal
or see a doctor like normal please don't
make learning the number one priority
like staying sane
and just having a healthy lifestyle and
having serenity those are the top
priority and thank you very much for
uh coming right out and saying that at
the beginning angie because that's one
thing i want to
uh definitely emphasize to everybody
like you don't need to make personal
sacrifices significant personal
sacrifices
uh i mean you may have to give up
playing fortnite or watching netflix for
a few hours but you
but you shouldn't be giving up sleep you
shouldn't be giving up
prayer or meditation or however it is
that you stay centered um
emma what are your thoughts on
prioritizing and figuring out what you
want to learn during this period
definitely i just want to reiterate what
angie said because i
believe that that is um
vital right now is you can't learn new
skills if
you are not okay as a person so first
and foremost take care of yourself
um you know i've been struggling with
motivation
the past few weeks i was actually
supposed to go visit my family
for the first time in over a year and i
had to cancel that trip so i won't see
them for another year
and so for me mentally that was really
hard but i was also in the midst of
preparing for
technical interviews and so i had to
balance
studying and learning new skills with
the emotional distress of
living in a foreign country and being
isolated from my family
so it kind of all depends on your
personal goals so if your goal is to
look for a new job because many of us
have been laid off
which is very unfortunate kind of come
up with a plan for yourself you know
looking for a full-time job is
is a full-time job so figure out what
you need to learn
and kind of chunk those into digestible
pieces
every single day don't all wear work
yourself but if your goal is to
improve your skills and your day job or
to learn something new find what you're
passionate about
or pick one skill to learn really really
well
this is the time to become t-shaped so
having you know vertical knowledge in
one area but also branching out to new
areas
and just picking up tangential skills is
really important and uh
you know not to just be totally all
about free code camp even though i'm a
fan girl um
i did use free code camp a lot the past
several weeks and
it landed me a new job a dream job so
i personally would recommend it to
anyone looking to
improve their skills and web development
okay
thank you very much for the uh we're
we're so thrilled to hear about uh your
new job and and we're excited like
of course whenever you get a new job you
want to like focus on getting that but
at some point we would love to have a a
write-up from you about your
your path to getting that job and the
decisions you made and how you did it
along the way
um absolutely thank you emma uh
that wall so you have a really deep
knowledge of this but
maybe you want to say something about uh
balance because i know you're very
athletic
and a lot of things you enjoy doing
you're not able to do at the moment
yeah i usually love to play badminton
and that's
i've been doing remote for a few years
now and badminton was my one contact
with society
so i tried to you know work out at home
or
in uh for a long time uh while working
on class central
uh badminton was the only thing that got
me away from it so
i think you should there are other
things that you can learn which
are not stressful which are not job
related
so you can also start learning just for
fun
so that it does so there is no pressure
that you need to understand the material
i would specifically recommend a course
called learning how to learn
which also sets you up for like other
courses that will do in the future
and it's also very entertaining and a
light course
that i took a few years ago and it's
some of the techniques that i learned in
that course
applies to every day
awesome yes barbara oakley she's an
amazing
university professor but also just
teacher and she's very passionate about
learning and that really comes through
in that course
and i believe that's the most popular
course
on that's the most popular mooc of all
massive open online courses
uh is it still i think it's
one it's it's that one or it's andrew
ing's machine learning course
one of those two yeah and and by the way
just to reiterate if you ever wondered
about
massive open online courses like these
free university courses you keep hearing
about
uh dubbal is dare i say one of the
world's foremost experts
on this having run class central for how
many years at this point seven eight
years
eight years eight and a half yeah eight
and a half yeah
so any questions anybody has about
university courses this is a perfect
time to ask them i'm just gonna
very quickly read a couple comments uh
from the chat uh
uh catalan pitt uh uh said
coming from someone who suffered from
severe anxiety and burnout
nothing is more precious than your
health take care of yourself
everyone and beth jackson said i love
how angie and emma
uh started with uh just giving us all
permission to check in with ourselves
and how we're feeling so
there's uh i i've been gathering
questions
uh from both uh the hashtag lockdown
conf and
just monitoring the chat and if anybody
asks the question that i'm like oh this
is a great question i'm going to feel
that
i will i'll do so so be sure to ask in
chat or tweet with the hashtag
lockdowncomp
uh but i'd like to know a little bit
about time management so
high management slash procrastination
management
uh let's start with you angie because i
know you're uh precocious
and you learn a whole lot and uh you're
constantly learning new things
um how do you manage your time and how
do you keep yourself
moving forward even without like some
structure to
impose upon you to force you to perform
and learn new things
yeah um it was really difficult for me
for a while because i
i am ambitious and i want to learn like
all the things
and do all the things and it was really
difficult to keep up
and i'm sure we've all been in a place
where you start some tutorial and you
never finish it or you
start some side project and then it
starts collecting dust
i'm known on twitter for spanking
people's hands
when they buy new domain names that
they're never going to use
what i've learned to do is uh is form
systems
for example my go-to
is trello so i use trello
to manage everything my work my
side project my side projects my
learning everything like i make cards
for them
um and that was working for a little
while and then it stopped working
um and so i went a step further just to
be a little bit more rigid and
actually put like dates on all of the
cards you know like
at work and you know here here's where
i'm slotting out the date some people
also use their calendars in a similar
way like
okay let me block out this time
for learning or whatever right um and so
i'm i'm not that structured like i don't
like
oh at six o'clock i have to do x y and z
um so i i do it in the form of days so
today here are the five things i would
like to do
and i have that today column
on my um trello board or whatever and so
i
kind of plan it i might take like
a sunday or something and plan out my
week um and that way i'm making sure i'm
getting done the things that i want to
get done
including the things for my own
professional development
okay awesome it sounds very organized
and a systematic approach
procrastination yeah but there's one
issue with that
uh managing the trello board is people
often forget to revisit that board uh
like
once you move with your day-to-day uh
life
uh you get you come across something
which is
more important than what you had
actually planned so how do you manage
those
how do you try to stay uh in the same
schedule that you had actually planned
what's your trick angie yeah i live out
of this board so
i don't know about you all but in the
world of so many distractions
even before covet um you kind of just
get sidetracked a lot like what am i
supposed to be doing
what was i working on you know so i live
out of this board so i never forget to
come back to it because i forget what
i'm supposed to be doing
and so it's like oh let me go to my
board oh yeah yeah this was the task
that i needed to do next and you're
right things do come up my boss might
contact me like angie i need a blog post
asap it's like that wasn't really on my
list of things today
so you kind of you know reprioritizing
and although it sounds structured
trust me i'm like very kind of fluid
so um i don't mind like changing a date
on something like okay well i guess i'm
not going to be able to
um read emma's new blog post today
let me put that for tomorrow or
something
great yeah and how about you emma
what what approaches have you used
um so i think my biggest um i'm taking
notes because i don't want to forget
this point i think it's
really important so i'm going to start
with the fact that
i am definitely one of those people who
like takes a ton of courses
and like has to finish them i can't
start one and not finish it like
it's the same with reading books so i
like waste a lot of time and i'll
honestly
taking courses that i don't need to be
taking but in any case
um i like to think about learning
as kind of like from the financial world
perspective learning about finances
and how if you're gonna buy something
large think about how much time you have
until you need to buy that thing
and then kind of amortize that over
every single day that you
um have until the deadline so if i have
an interview coming up in two weeks
what are all the things that i need to
learn and let's amortize learning all of
those things over every single day let's
break it up into even pieces so you're
not completely overwhelmed
so i did that when i was studying for
technical interviews
but i never pushed myself so if i
mentally was not in
a place where i knew i could digest
information i wouldn't i wouldn't learn
it's just uh it's not practical to push
yourself if you're not in
a learning mind space um but that being
said there's also this concept of
intentional procrastination which is
something that i practice so
it's pushing tasks off um
to a later time but in the in the back
of your mind like your subconscious mind
is putting pieces together
um so if i have a big project like i
won't start working on it right away
because likely all of this
that work i'm going to be doing is going
to change over the course of
a week so as opposed to doing all that
work i'm actually just
processing it in the back of my mind
push off the tangible work until a later
date and by that point i've kind of
worked out the kinks in my head
but there's a really great book called
um
uh why we sleep and it talks about how
we form new connections when we're
sleeping so make sure you're getting
enough sleep it's more important than
you think
you can't actually build new not new
memories but you can't
build new synapses create new synapses
in your brain to learn these new
concepts if you're not sleeping enough
so that's my my biggest tip
right intentional practice
procrastination did i get that right
yeah that's definitely the term
of the day for me because it seems like
almost
yeah it seems like a self-contradictory
term but
that makes so much sense because you're
right so much of the work is gonna
is gonna change down the road thanks for
sharing that with us and
and just to be 100 clear the name of
that book again
why we sleep um why we sleep yeah
there's another one called make it stick
that i haven't read yet it's next up on
my docket but it's about
how different learning styles uh kind of
work
the the most efficiently with you and
your preferred learning style so if i
like to watch
video tutorials that might actually not
be the most efficient way for me to
learn so
i'd also recommend that one awesome
thanks for the book recommendations just
a pop quiz what time did everybody go to
sleep last night in your local time zone
3 am no that hurts
me i did 11 11 pm
okay great so yeah
i usually sleep at 4 00 a.m so my
goodness
well to be fair everyone's like uh what
are those called your cycles i'm losing
my english uh everyone's circadian
rhythms are different
especially through ages but like i'm
usually in bed by ten not gonna lie
that's great no it's great to hear both
angie
and emma are uh early sleeper or
relatively early sleepers
um yeah no i just knew i had to be here
at the crack of dawn but
so just for some context for everybody
tuning in you may be wondering like if
you're in california why is this
conference so
so early well we have lots of friends in
in uh in asia and uh
and uh eastern europe uh we just wanted
to make sure
that especially down in australia
oceanica like we wanted to make sure
that they were
able to to come as well and the best
time to do things generally
it's like really early u.s time it kind
of inconveniences americans but
it's it makes it possible for everybody
else to attend without having to stay up
super duper late
so uh thanks if you're one of those
people who like woke up super early to
watch this
we appreciate it uh you're taking one
for the entire global team
and uh dawah let's let's talk about you
like time management
uh and managing procrastination what are
some
insights you've had on that yeah i mean
i'm very similar to emma and uh what she
talked about intentional procrastination
uh or uh barbara oakley actually calls
it like diffused mode of thinking
so what are like some of these uh
concepts are
you see them across different
productivity books
so like learning how to learn is what
taught me about uh
refuse mode of thinking and it made me
comfortable with procrastination
so i don't really do a lot of time
management right now
i just have a simple sublime text list
which keeps growing
and if it's not important i don't come
back to it you know
so and i try like i think my biggest
step has been for me is
not to feel guilty about procrastination
so especially when you're creating
something new it's
you know i think procrastination is
natural and yeah
i usually sit on that let it sit in my
head for a while and
it's usually when you get to it you do
it much faster
i think it has such a negative
connotation classically
and i i would love to change that stigma
i think it can be used as a tool
if you use it properly
right procrastination can be kind of a
compass
needle that shows you where you actually
need to go because the one thing that
you
are procrastinating is probably the most
important thing that you need to do
right
yeah i also really quickly i'm gonna
throw out one more book recommendation
because it's
great in terms of achieving your goals
especially when you're trying to learn
and that's atomic habits by james clear
and i promote this book every chance i
get because it's my favorite
but essentially it talks about instead
of setting goals just make sure you're
on the right trajectory to achieving
some sort of mindset but also change
your mindset so like if you
are trying to quit smoking for example
identify as a non-smoker as opposed to
saying i don't smoke
or i'm sorry as opposed to saying like
oh i quit smoking so i'm not
a smoker uh and changing your mindset
and saying i am a full stack developer
that will help you achieve these
milestones and make sure you're on the
right trajectory
that that's great very practical advice
uh just a very simple little mind hack
that you can do
to overcome imposter syndrome and uh one
of our
you know our prolific and and community
members
over the years uh danny with gdg memphis
was just asking
i'm gonna quote his question verbatim is
very well phrased uh
with the current times and with mental
health being a big subject
how do you deal with imposter syndrome
and how do you deal with the doubts that
you're facing especially
during the lockdown and i'll just open
that up to anybody who wants to jump in
and has
thoughts on that
it's really long so i teach like an
inspired
workshop on like combating
imposter syndrome i'll try to be very
brief here
um focus on the things that
you know you know um imposter syndrome
is something that
people of all levels of success
suffer with right um what really hit
home for me is a
quote um from maya angelou who is you
know
just profound and world-renowned and
uh she was like yeah i've written x
number of books something like you know
19 books or something and every time i
write the next one is when i think that
the world is going to figure out i'm a
fraud
and it's like wow somebody who clearly
is an expert an inspiration to an entire
generation
feels that you know she's not good
enough and she suffers
with imposter syndrome as well so
um it really just helped me like okay
this is a thing it's a goofy thing
and um and we gotta get over it right
and so some
i'll give you one trick that um i use
with people
who i know suffer with um impostor
syndrome
and it could be like um like just write
down
take maybe 30 seconds
um give yourself 30 seconds to like two
minutes
and write down 10 things that
you're good at right and that timer
there is going to help you cheat the
imposter syndrome because
it doesn't have time to get in your head
and talk to talk you out of it
you're just writing it down quickly
before you can second guess yourself
and then at the end of that you look at
that and reflect on it
and it's like wow i have 10 things that
i'm pretty good at that's
that's really great you know um
kick that imposter syndrome out
yeah i love that i want to reiterate
what
you said about the fact that everyone
regardless of where you are in your
career
how much money you make where you come
from how many followers you have
everyone
experiences imposter syndrome and me
personally i don't think i'll ever get
over it people ask how do you get over
it i don't think i ever will
um but i don't know that that's a bad
thing because it keeps me
working hard um i will say
try to recognize your small wins if you
can recognize all these small things
that you do that will compound over time
you'll recognize how far you've come
but i also kind of just want to
challenge the question of like what is
an
expert like there's no definition of
what exactly you have to have skill set
wise to be considered an expert
um and you don't need to be an expert to
have valuable information
so you know your your journey is unique
and no one
will ever walk that same journey as you
which means you are
viewing the world and your experiences
through a different lens of someone else
so your information and what you're
teaching
even if it's been done a thousand times
if you want to teach react hooks
um do it like absolutely because the way
that
you've learned it might resonate with
someone else who was struggling with the
concept
so i would say you know recognize your
small wins and
just try to
realize that everyone feels this way
it's not just you
can i piggyback on what emma said real
quickly
on um owning like your expertise and
your
your voice is so important um
like emma said there's going to be
dozens
of blog posts tutorials or whatever
on a certain topic and maybe you want to
speak on that topic because you just
learned about it and you want to
write on like you know a hash note or
something like that
um and you're like oh well you know the
the great expert has
already written about it who am i to
write about it
let me tell you um when i'm learning
trying to learn something
and think about it from your own point
of view you google whatever the topic is
and you
find like a bunch of results and you go
to like
one of them right and that one's not
clicking for you so you go to the
second one and then maybe you go to the
third one um there's sometimes
it's not until like the fifth or sixth
one that i go to that is like
okay this is speaking to me and how i
learned this
is great the other ones are in a
different
learning style are taught in a different
style that
doesn't resonate with me as well right
so don't be afraid to put out content
that is already out there your voice and
your approach
is the differentiator
[Music]
so what other thoughts you all have as
far as
uh just
using that confidence that you're
getting uh these these same techniques
that you're using to overcome imposter
syndrome in terms of
uh approaching the
you know the meta of learning the code
and going out and getting new developer
jobs and working as a developer
how would you use those same or similar
techniques
to learning a new topic for example it
is very common for people to get
stressed out
about learning new mathematical concepts
like if you wanted to learn
linear algebra for example and you
wanted to get uh
it's a very commonly used form of
mathematics and software development
especially these days with like all the
machine learning
uh tools out there and how would you
yourself pump yourself up if you wanted
to sit down and like i'm gonna learn
some
linear algebra this weekend what would
your process be
i think you need to find your why this
is another book i could just open up
you know a conference to talk about
books find your why
is start with why i'm sorry by simon
sinek um
he talks a lot about the reasoning
behind why we do things if you
can sit there and tell yourself i want
to learn linear algebra because
it will help me get a job at nasa i
don't know maybe that's one of the
requirements
um as opposed to i need to learn this
it's going to change your mindset um and
it's i get to learn this right like i
have the ability to learn this that's
not something everyone get
you know has the the privilege or the
ability to do so for me it wasn't
uh i have to study for technical
interviews it was i get the opportunity
to interview for an incredible job
and that is my driving force
great
so um i would like to bring focus on
like how do you measure success like you
have talk uh you have spoken about
how do you manage your tasks uh how do
you
pick books how do you pick resources how
do you stay motivated
but during this pandemic since a lot of
things are happening at the same time
you're hearing news from presidents you
are hearing
news uh breaking news from so many
different areas
how do you measure your success like how
do you measure what you have learned
and what you have not learned and
because right now nobody is validating
those things
you are not attending interviews so how
do you measure your success
during this pandemic time
i take small wins i'm going to focus on
the learning piece of it
um so start in the course yay
me like i i am my biggest cheerleader
right
um and that helps fight imposter
syndrome as well
so yay me i started a course yay me i
finished a
chapter and you know i got a pretty good
result on the quiz there um gay me i've
actually
finished this course you're going to
hear about it on twitter
yeah i did it and then i take it a step
further as well right because we all
know that you can watch a tutorial but
it's
especially on coding but until you
actually code yourself
it's really hard to retain that
information
and so um then i want to go build
something you know i'm going to take it
a step
further and it doesn't have to be a big
huge app just something that's
exercising what it is that i learned and
yep i'm going to have to
go back to that tutorial because some of
the things i forgot
i don't quite remember the syntax i
don't beat myself
up about that that's normal right we're
i'm
new to this um and that's okay forgive
yourself
yup that's why the resources are there
keep consulting it right
and it's not just one problem i might
say okay now let me do another problem
and after maybe two or three of those
i'm not checking those resources
as much anymore that's a win i count
those small wins all day long
absolutely yeah
go ahead oh it's class central was a
side project for me so
it was the same thing i was trying to
get better at php and i started
it as a side project a one-page site to
list all the courses
from stanford and i just happened to be
at the right place right time
and for the first two years it was a
side project
and i kept adding new things just for
the
fun of it and i'm lucky now it's my job
but i think finding a project finding
some sort of
thing that you're passionate about and
then building something around it is
is a good way to sort of implement what
you're learning
uh courses sometimes can give you a
false sense of
learning so trying to do something
that's not
following a script of a project or that
somebody else
gave it to you can be a good way to
actually
test yourself and figure out what you
have not
learned right right
i am i just quickly wanted to mention a
couple of things
so for me success is success is
subjective
um but for me success is not a salary or
a job title it's a mindset
and i for me
i realize i'm successful if i post a
piece of content
and it helps one person that makes me
feel successful um
but just to kind of visualize these
things print out
uh like a chart or whatever and you've
got like
different values on there and you every
time you complete a course for example
you color in a square
or something so i do this when i'm
paying off all my medical debt but i
still have in the us
like fill in hundred or thousand dollar
increments right and every time you pay
off a thousand dollars color it in
you can apply that same thing to taking
courses or
um you know having successful github
repos that aren't
half alive like all of mine are i mean
every time you take a course or you
uh close a pull request like color it in
and those visual reinforcements
will help you stay motivated right
awesome so visualizing your learning it
like mapping it out
uh do you all use any sort of tools to
build like roadmaps of what you're going
to learn
or to how would you organize okay let me
just
ask a very open-ended high-level
question okay
you decide that you need to that you've
always been relatively weak in
mathematics
uh maybe you got through like the high
school stuff and you kind of dodged or
took the easier
math courses in university the the
easiest required ones
uh you know or you didn't even go to
university and like basically your math
stopped at like high school
geometry or trigonometry or something i
mean if you're in the us i know in like
china you would learn way more than that
by the time you finished high school
but um let's say
that you want to go back and fill in the
gaps how would you just using what you
already know about learning lots of
about qa or learning a whole lot about
uh
you know software engineering concepts
uh learning new programming languages
using what you know from your years and
years of actually learning things
new on your own and on the job how would
you go about tackling that task
how would you decide what to do let's
just start from from
day one you sit down you decide that you
need to learn this new thing
and we'll just say like you need to
learn linear algebra since that's what i
mentioned if you already know linear
algebra don't worry about this maybe you
can choose a different math
this one and we'll go ahead and just
start with uh we'll start with emma
yeah so first of all i did terribly in
math like i basically failed calculus if
you're also bad at math
it's fine i just want to throw that out
there but um what i like to do
is on one piece of printer paper
i write down everything that's related i
create almost like a graph structure
where i'll start with the main topic
i'm going to use data structures and
algorithms because for me i can talk
about that more freely so
if i need to learn data structures and
algorithms all right what data
structures do i need
break that down okay i need to learn
things that are already built into
javascript arrays
objects sets things like that well what
other things do i need to learn that
aren't built into javascript
linked lists uh you know hash tables i
don't know whatever other one stacks
cues
and kind of just create a little map of
my for myself on one piece of paper
and then based on those things what are
the things i already am confident in
color those in um and for the things
that i need to work on
what resources can i use to learn those
and i create like a playlist
i saw someone in the chat mention notion
i use notion all day
every day i also use the things app to
create different lists
like a to-do application um
and between those two i just kind of
keep tabs on the different resources
that i would like to
watch to fill in those knowledge gaps
okay awesome and how would you tackle
that angie
yeah i'll be honest like sometimes when
i'm about to learn something new i'm not
quite sure of um
what's what am i supposed to be learning
exactly right it's a new concept i just
know let's say i'm going for a job or
something
and i need to know react right
um given that all i know is the word
react i don't know anything about it i
don't know
i don't even know how to examine the
courses that i could look at to see okay
what does this course cover versus this
course i don't know what i'm supposed to
be looking for
so in um situations like that i need to
figure out like
okay what's the best course for me what
is it that i need to learn here
and with that i seek out other people
right um you don't have to do this all
and figure it out on your own
i'll give you a little tip though don't
send people like generic
questions of um hey i want to learn
react where should i start
right because that could be a really big
answer and
people if they don't know you might not
take the time out to answer those types
of things
so try to be like very specific i need
to learn react
because i want to do x y and z
maybe here are two or three courses that
i'm considering do you have any
opinions on you know which one of these
would best
get me to point b where i'm trying to
get to
right so that's a more specific question
so figuring out like okay what is it
that i even need to learn
i'm finding that course again i have to
block out the time
otherwise the day gets away from me so
i'll say okay i'm going to take this
course it says that this course is six
hours long um okay where can i squeeze
six hours in
and i'm scheduling it out like maybe i
only have
30 minutes or an hour that i can devote
to something a day
so okay let me make my little trello
cards with 30 minute slots
um i can probably squeeze it in on
monday and then again on thursday and
then maybe
you know tuesday or whatever so figure
out um and be realistic with yourself
don't try
to squeeze in more than you know you
have time for
um space it out if it takes you three
weeks to get through
six hour course that is okay you know
um you've done it you've gotten through
it versus trying to do six
hours and one day which is not that
realistic for a lot of people
yeah i just i wanna i wanna say plus one
to everything angie just said
100 because like half the time i have no
idea where to start and it's just a
dumpster fire
but secondly um don't memorize solutions
understand the concepts and it's gonna
take longer to do that
but if you're interviewing for example
um if you just memorize solutions but
can't
under don't understand the underlying
foundations it's going to be
nearly impossible for you to explain
this to an interviewer so
be patient with yourself because
understanding concepts takes a lot
longer than memorizing
but it will go a lot a long way
awesome and i just want to highlight
what jillian keenan said in chat
uh she said i think a really good way to
determine knowledge gaps is to ask
yourself
can you teach this to someone else maybe
if you i mean
there's always the rubber duck method if
you're if you're social distancing
completely by yourself
but if you're with your partner or if
you've got kids around you could try to
teach them
a little bit and and uh you know there's
the saying
i can't remember who said it but it was
in my email blast that i sent last week
it says
teaching is learning twice um and
you know you figure out the gaps in your
own knowledge when you try to teach
someone else
i want to make sure we get an answer
from daw although because i know
he's just been this is what he does he
eats sleeps and breathes
uh continuing education uh dalwal
how many moocs have you completed by the
way at this point you think
probably a dozen not too many okay yeah
but still i mean that's like the
equivalent of like
doing a graduate degree it's like 12 12
courses right
but yeah how would you how would you
tackle learning a big
ambiguous new field of study
i think i would try to find a starter
course
that allows me to put like five to 10
hours
and just making sure it's good enough
and try to do a speed run through it
basically understand like you don't have
to understand everything but just to
know what you don't know and
i think that will help you understand
then from there on it would help you
plan out
better i think we sometimes try to
optimize
things that we don't even know so i
think just getting started as quickly as
possible
is something i would uh try to do
instead of
because you can go down the internet
rabbit hole for of the best courses
uh reddit commands you know like
everywhere and then
you might actually spend up more time
finding a course then
doing some sort of a short course that
could take a few hours
right right and uh i would like to bring
focus on
uh something that's uh happening in the
internet right now that most of the
companies like coursera and
egghead they are opening up their
courses they are giving the courses for
free
so what are your thoughts on that like
do you think this is the right time
for developers to grab this opportunity
and learn as much as possible or
should they focus on picking the right
topic on these platforms and just
completing few i think definitely
picking the right topics
um like places like free code camp
always have free content
i run test automation university we have
free courses on programming and
testing and all the things development
um and yeah i think it's great that
other platforms like pluralsight and
things are opening up their content
right now
for free but i wouldn't recommend like
oh let me
start all the things right if you have
10 tutorials
going the likelihood of you finishing
them all is
very small even the likelihood of
finishing one probably goes down when
you've started so many
figure out what it is that you want to
learn and i'm sure a lot of us have like
backlists
of things that we've always wanted to do
and now maybe we have a little bit
extra time um and so it feels like we
should
probably tackle that entire list no
think about like
i don't know what are you most
passionate about or what do you
need right away for your current job or
your next job or you know
what's just something interesting that
you would want to learn and maybe pick
one and start that i don't know do any
of you do like multiple tutorials in
parallel i
i personally have to do like one at a
time yeah don't do
it um i learned this the hard way
um i your time and your willpower are
depletable resources so you need to use
them efficiently and effectively
and i'm the kind of person that has
shiny object syndrome like i see a
tutorial i want to take it and i start
it but what that means is
i'm actually learning the skills that
are relevant to me right now
so um i would definitely recommend
sticking with one
because human beings like to think we
can multitask but we can't
great yeah i mean i would agree to
trying to i that's why i usually prefer
like full courses which are like almost
a month long or something so
once you start something you don't have
to think too much in terms of finding
resources
you just do one single curriculum it's
like what it's one storyline
so hopefully it's coherent so you're
building on top of the knowledge week
after week
and that's why you generally have a
preference for university courses
uh if i can jump in and just say like
the reason free codecamp is a single
linear curriculum is precisely to avoid
what angie and emmer are talking about
shiny object syndrome
historically universities just had a
single major everybody just studied
liberal arts and that was like you learn
greek and you learn latin you learn math
and you learn all these different
topics but everybody learned the exact
same thing
and everybody in the world who went to
college essentially learned the same
general body of knowledge
and we've gotten away from that with
like all these different electives and
it makes sense if you're like learning
nursing that you shouldn't have to
necessarily learn
um you know
i'm i'm trying to think of a good a good
analogy here but
but you wouldn't necessarily need to
learn uh
a lot of different skills if you were
going to become a super specialist but
i would argue that we should have a more
generalistic uh you know university
experience and then people can
specialize on the job
uh but anyway to to try to
blunt the uh the power of shiny into
object syndrome of grabbing your
attention pulling you away from what you
need to do and
ultimately serving as a tool for
procrastination we decided very early
that free cooking would have a single
linear curriculum
and people would work from the top to
the bottom and there wouldn't be a bunch
of forks in the road
uh because generally when your
university's asking you to choose
electives
they're they're basically asking you to
make a decision
in a relatively uninformed way um
yeah i like that free code camp is
linear but it's kind of like a la carte
in a sense because you can start
anywhere you don't have to start at the
beginning
um which is really invaluable like you
have a clear path but you don't have to
follow that path
if you don't fit into it
yeah and i i don't want to talk too much
about free code camp on this because
there's no way you're here
like everybody watching wants to hear
from you all but i will say like
it's highly informed from like video
game design and i think
the future of education you can see it
in video games
uh that that it's not only fun but it's
almost addictive
if we can make learning addictive then
we've truly won
and uh we're truly going to have like a
really uh
enlightened uh populist
so we still have about six minutes five
and a half minutes left
uh fuzzil do you did you have any
closing questions that you wanted to ask
to the panel
yeah i'm just going through the twitter
feed and uh someone uh
recently asked one question uh which is
like really interesting and something we
keep on seeing on astronaut every time
which is like uh oh my god
uh like how do you uh
overcome uh the um that someone else is
doing better than you
uh has learned something really good and
has created a really popular open source
project
and i am some and i am somebody who is
lagging behind
so again like as emma has spoken about
the self motivation
so what tips do you have for beginners
who are feeling this way
i always tell people beginners
experts anybody there's a philosophy i
follow where
i think about it as running a race right
and when i'm running my race i'm looking
ahead
and focusing on my own path and yeah i
might
glance over to other people who are
running but my
focus is on my race right and if you
stare too hard at other people think
about the momentum
that you're losing because you're not
focused ahead
and that's true in life if you're so
focused on everyone else's journey
that's time and energy and momentum
and self-confidence that you're losing
focus on your own race everyone has
different circumstances right
i'm at home i don't have kids
my job is very flexible so i probably
can do more than someone else who has
five children at home and a partner who
is sick
and you know their fever is running high
and you know it's just
a lot of different circumstances don't
focus on other people's journey you
don't really know their story you don't
know how many times
that they've fallen down this might be
their third attempt at the thing
that this is your first attempt at right
and maybe that's why they're moving a
little faster
it could be a million different reasons
don't focus on it because you're losing
momentum in your own race
focus on your race i also think too
this is an important message which is
computers are binary but humans aren't
and so you're like and you mentioned
your journey is not going to have
feature parody with another person
so focus on who you were are today and
compare that to who you were yesterday
right right so there's a tip for all the
big nerd developers don't get
intimidated by someone else's success
focus on your own journey
do you want to add something yeah yeah i
know i know i don't want to monopolize
this but
someone else's success does not take
away from your success
so you know unless you're applying for
the same job but don't compare yourself
to anyone else
um focus on yourself and be genuinely
happy for others who are doing well
because again it doesn't impact your
success
right yeah i think so many people get in
this kind of scarcity mindset where
they're like
feeling like they're competing with
other people that are their peers but
the reality is you know the world is a
big place i mean we can't even
fathom seven billion people like
our brains can't capacitate those like
that scale of numbers
and uh you know nobody understands how
everything works nobody understands how
the market works how
different companies are able to bring in
revenue and survive it's a complex
ecosystem
and uh within all that ambiguity you can
be assured that there is a tremendous
amount of
opportunity i mean we've somehow managed
for most of modern human history to keep
a bulk of people employed after this
pandemic passes
there are going to be new opportunities
out there and you're not going to be
competing head to head with people
around you
in some abstract way you'll be competing
in the sense that the more entrants into
a field potentially
you know the the more uh supply and
demand
demand uh is met and price goes down as
a result
but that's only going to have a very
small marginal impact
on you in practice all these people
that are here in this chat room with you
that are watching this video with you
they're your allies and you have so much
more to gain
from collaborating with them than you
have to lose from them also succeeding i
mean
it it really is true like other people's
success
is your success and celebrating other
people's success is a great way to build
rapport with them because that's the
moment that they
really are proud of and that they want
other people to jump in uh
any closing thoughts before we end this
panel just there have been so many
great things that you all have said
focus on your own race your own journey
is something angie said and just a
minute ago
emma said your journey is not going to
have feature parody with another person
great great use of uh software uh
analogy there
all right well we are going to uh i just
want to thank
everyone for joining uh we're going to
take a
five to ten minute break there are going
to be slides playing there's gonna be
music from bass rebels which is this
great
youtube channel with with copyright free
music uh that we can listen to
uh while and jam out and just chat uh
tweet questions for the next panel the
next panel is going to be
um how to work successfully from home
without going crazy
and i just want to thank our phenomenal
guests for everything
that they've brought to the table here
and that they've shared with us angie
jones up in san francisco uh be sure to
scroll down in the description there
again there are links to everybody's
twitter you should absolutely follow
emma you should absolutely follow angie
and dal wall uh of course uh emma thank
you for joining us
from germany congratulations on your
dream job we're all excited
you know a few weeks after you've
settled in maybe months after you this
is what you're going to be doing you're
going to be learning all the different
uh tacit knowledge associated with
working at that company so that's what
you're probably going to be doing but
once that slows down and you have time
we'd love for a check-in
on the free code camp publication you
got it and then
daw wall thank you again for everything
you are doing with class central you're
taking all these huge you know this huge
volume of free online courses and you're
making it uh
searchable and you're giving people
qualitative feedback on
you know like you can read the anecdotes
from somebody who actually went through
the course what they thought of the
course
and then you can see like it's just like
amazon like you know the star review
system
so you can find the best courses for
different topics and of course
dawah also frequently publishes lists of
the best courses based on data
so thank you uh everyone for joining
fazel and i will be right back in about
five minutes with a new panel
thank you thank you for your time it was
nice talking to you all bye
thanks for having me bye bye bye
everyone have a beautiful day
hey everybody welcome back uh
i'm quincy larson with free code camp uh
of course joined
by my uh co-mc puzzle
with hashnow.com and hey guys
hey puzzle um and we this panel
is about how to work productively from
home
and stay sane and we're going to be
talking with three people who
probably have a combined total of at
least a decade or two
of working from home uh
tons of wisdom here if you're just
starting working from home
this is the panel for you you're gonna
learn all the little tricks and hacks
that these people have picked up
over the years uh so i'm gonna go ahead
and i'm i'm thrilled
to introduce you to our guests
these are prominent developers from the
community uh
many of whom uh i've interviewed
on the free cocaine podcast where we
publish like videos of their workflows
and things like that
so i'll start with uh colleen schneidel
schnetler and and she is
a freelance developer in the arlington
virginia area she has three kids and she
manages to work from home
while her three kids are not like
farging in and completely disrupting her
all day which is quite an accomplishment
uh we also have jessica chan from the
austin
area in texas um
and jessica is the coder coder you may
have heard of her or
checked out her in incredible instagram
which is just
filled with programming tips and it's
just
it's one of my favorite instagrams i
strongly recommend
you all check it out and uh and then of
course we have sid
who's in uh he's in amsterdam
and he works for code sandbox which you
may have heard of it's a new
relatively new coding playground where
you can go and build projects right in
the browser
he was previously at off zero again
both jessica and sid have extensive
experience working remotely as well
so uh welcome
thank you yeah so uh
just just to start off like
what has changed over the past month and
a half
for each of you maybe you could describe
how
the pandemic is affecting your your
day-to-day life
and and we can we can start with uh
jessica
sure well i have been working remotely
for maybe the past four years or so so
it's kind of weird because
on a day-to-day basis even before this
all happened i wasn't really
i didn't have like a huge active you
know life
outside the house i would you know stay
indoors do my work
and so day to day a lot of things have
stayed
really the same but obviously i think
just
knowing what's going on in the world
right now and you know not being able to
say visit family and friends in person
that's definitely been
a huge change um and just kind of moving
from
in-person meet-ups with friends to you
know house party
or you know different hangouts with
friends instead so it's just kind of
moving into the online virtual space
like we're doing now awesome
uh and how about you colleen so
our lives have been completely upended
because of the
the children um are no longer going to
school and
in the state of virginia they have
cancelled school for the rest of the
school year
so it's been a month now my kids are
three
six and eight and none of them are um
in school we don't have any child care
options so
it's i mean it's been really hard i've
got to be honest like it has been
okay i have a second grader so he should
probably learn something
the kindergartner and the three-year-old
like they'll be okay
um so trying to balance like this
homeschooling which
i am not a teacher um i've challenged
i've been very it's been very
challenging bad and like still finding
the time for work
yeah i can only imagine i i have two
kids and it's it's crazy enough but
yeah again they're they're not
school-aged so we don't have to really
worry about teaching them
um and sid how about you how has uh
calvin 19 impacted your day-to-day life
out there in amsterdam
so i'm closer to jessica on this one
that on the surface
it's kind of the same like i was working
remotely the whole team works remotely
but i want to say that it doesn't feel
like the usual at all like it feels very
very weird
at home there's been like some tiny
changes we had to make because my wife
also works at home now so we're like
this this is the meeting room and the
dining table is the co-working space
so it's like we can't have like we can't
sit at the same place and have meetings
at the same time
so we're like constantly booking the
conference room
uh but other than that it just it feels
weird
but like it's my life overall probably
hasn't been impacted as much
right i don't know about you guys but do
you feel like like i feel like just the
stress of the whole situation
has really impacted my ability to focus
too so there's been kind of third order
effects like checking the news and
seeing what's going on and then trying
to work definitely right
right yeah i've had to push myself back
from keeping up to date on the news
because it was kind of getting a little
too much and just affecting
your mental state right right
so as you know like there are a lot of
companies who had never heard about work
from home concept
so this is like the first time they are
introduced to and
i keep getting complaints from my
colleagues my friends and they are
saying like none of the work is
happening is actually happening so
things that were supposed to take one
day of time
it's like they're taking seven days of
time to finish so what advice do you
have for developers
who are introduced to work from home
environment for the first time
so yeah i said you can go ahead first
i can start i kind of feel bad for them
because
this isn't remote this is like this is
not how
remote jobs usually are so they've kind
of been thrown into this
without preparation without being set up
for this
so i'm feeling like and to be honest
it's not just them
even remote teams like mine are probably
working
at like 50 productivity right right now
so i'd say that's just kind of the way
it is right now because of like the
stress and
like it's just hard to focus and get
things done right um
we can talk about tips soon but i just
want to like start by saying like
it's it would be harsh to like force
productivity on
anyone at this time and what's been
really useful in our team is just kind
of
having that conversation where like i
have a lot of guilt about not being
productive
because that's something i struggled
with anyways so just having that
conversation in the team
has been has been kind of like
comforting because i realize nobody is
at their best right now
so people are more forgiving than you
would imagine
right right
yeah i do think it comes down a lot to
just your company culture and how maybe
empathetic or sympathetic your manager
as well as the higher-ups your company
can be so i think
you know this unfortunately might be one
of your these your miles your mileage
may vary
situations um you know if your company
is really understanding and they
they know that you know there's parents
having to homeschool their kids and
there's more understanding in terms of
having expectations but
it can be difficult if you're working
for a company or a manager who's
expecting
you know the same or maybe even a higher
amount of productivity out of you
at this current time which is just not
really possible
[Music]
i just wanted to um just kind of like
this is
a great panel but i just want to come
out and acknowledge the fact that we're
all
five developers like everybody here on
this call we're five people who can
work from home and i think it it
we should it it requires saying that we
are extremely fortunate in this regard
many many people
uh cannot work remotely like
many people have to go and deliver
packages or they have to
work in a logistics center or they have
to work in a hospital
to help people who are sick many
many things do require physically
reporting to a specific location at a
specific time
and there is a tremendous amount of risk
associated with that
and so i just want to make sure
everybody watching realizes that we do
feel grateful for that reality and and
that uh
i i don't want anybody to get the
impression that we're you know a bunch
of entitled developers
talking about how our our productivity's
gone down 30 or something like that when
people are out there
like subjecting themselves to incredible
risks
uh them and their families uh so um
this should not be a dour panel because
we should be extremely happy i'm
extremely grateful like i i look at like
what i was doing before i was running a
school i was a school director before i
learned to code and became a developer
and i had students from all over the
world and they would fly in and
help with their their visa paperwork and
help with
you know just monitor the the teaching
staff and we had in-person instruction
and i think about how
that would have completely turned my
life upside down like i was working like
50 60 hours a week just making sure all
my teachers were happy all instruction
all the admin staff were happy have you
all
worked in fields other than software
development where working remotely would
not be possible
and how do you envision the difference
between
what life is like right now for you as a
developer and what life
would be like if you stayed in your old
field
um so i used to work uh in defense
and that was a job where we had to go
into the office because of the things we
did
and you know it's interesting you
brought this up because i was just
saying
to my friend the other day i was saying
like i hate to complain at all about the
situation because our situation is
better than 90
of the people in the world right now um
just because of
everything you said like i'm so lucky
that i made this transition
i mean at my old job like i assume we
would have lost our jobs like they can't
pay you if you know if you can't go to
work um
and just just this even now like because
i'm a consultant
contractor um i don't know if i'm gonna
have a job in three months
like i don't know if our current
contract our contract was supposed to be
renewed but now we're waiting so we
don't really know what's gonna happen
happen
and that's stressful but my partner also
works so between
we are so we have that safety net of a
dual income household
but i have so many friends who are
independent consultants and contractors
where they have one spouse that stays
home with the kids and one spouse that
works and
that anxiety and that stress of like am
i gonna have a job in three months like
i have to support this family like feed
these kids is
it can be i mean i just feel like it can
be overwhelming
yeah i can i can relate to that a little
so my first job was
in the environmental physics setup so my
job is literally to go
fill in tests
there's just stuff on it to see like how
much like co2 in the atmosphere and all
of that
this was before like i decided that i
don't want to do physics anymore
uh but what's interesting is like i
can't imagine doing that
right now because it's like we needed
like these giant
instruments that were only there in lab
it's like
you you just can't have that anymore and
like being the most junior person over
there
i'm pretty sure i'm the first one that
would lose the job right if the labs
like labs work on like funding and they
have to publish
research and in time like this there is
no research happening
like you can't publish anything so if
funding gets cut
it's it's the it's the people who put
the test tubes that lose the job first
yeah i used to work in higher ed in just
doing like administrative
uh office type work and i'd imagine as
you know many schools are either closing
closed or trying to go online like
my job probably would have been
eliminated at some point or would be
kind of on the edge so yeah definitely
feel very
fortunate and it's a tough situation for
a lot of people in terms of their
their work situation
yeah and i i know that many people
watching this
many of your jobs may have evaporated
and i just want to emphasize that
we uh we want to do everything we can
to help you find a new opportunity and
i'm i'm hopeful that this
uh this conference that we're doing will
be helpful in that regard
um somebody in in chat uh just
said he was laid off two weeks ago but
that
the benefit of being a developer is that
he can take
an idea or a problem and he can build
something that could potentially replace
that income
so let's talk about work from home tools
because that's a huge area of interest
right now in terms of like
like if you look at the companies that
are hiring right now many of them like
focus on remote productivity like
microsoft teams or slack or
zoom or some of these tools what is your
work from
home tool chain like and and
how do you stay productive and work with
your colleagues
remotely what are the main the main
tools you all use
well my uh my work uses slack for
everything
so everyone's on slack even before this
all happened i think they were
they have offices in different parts of
the world so they
had already kind of had this system set
up where everyone can communicate pretty
well and everyone sort of knows how to
you know do project management and other
things um
on online which has been pretty great so
i think yeah some chat tool whether
that's
slack or discord or you know maybe even
google hangouts i think is super helpful
yeah and how about you sid what are you
using over at code sandbox
um so i guess slack is the common one
view is zoom and we've recently gone
through a bunch of pair programming apps
um because everyone that we used was
having scaling problems
so like our default choices kind of went
went away
but we've like settled on tuple.app
which i think is
new to maybe it's not as popular so it's
working great for us
that plus zoom plus notion it's i i feel
like it's mostly communication
tools and we're doing a lot of
asynchronous communication these days
like a bunch of writing
more than they've ever done i think this
has just made us like better
at being remote than we were already
interesting so just just to highlight
what you just said there
working remotely is is kind of increase
everybody's
average level of communication skills
you'd say
i mean we we were already remote so we
had to communicate a bunch
but then you always had the option that
you know you could ping someone
and you could say let's let's chart it
this time or let's get on the zoom call
right
but even though we're like relatively
close by like i think everyone in the
team is in europe
they're kind of working different time
zones because somebody has a kid and
then they have to
you know sometimes they have to take the
morning while their partner takes the
evening
so it's like everyone's schedule has
kind of been just thrown off
so now it's most of the conversations
are asynchronous
and i think we've gotten into a good
habit of documenting
and just like passing on thoughts
processing them and then sharing them
uh otherwise we would just like get on a
zoom call and treat it like a
tap on the shoulder
yeah and how about you colleen what kind
of tools are you all using
so my teams use slack and zoom and
whereby
and google hangouts if we're feeling
lazy um so
just just those kind of communication
tools i think because i
this one team i'm working with um i i
agree that this has actually helped us
become more communicative which i think
has been great for our team
we're more likely to kind of jump on a
screen share than we were before this
happened which i'm not
exactly sure why um but but that
yeah so that's worked pretty well for us
okay awesome it sounds like somebody
might be washing dishes in the
background
if if your partner's washing dishes
please mute
um so uh
one question we have from uh
uh chat that i really wanna highlight
elliot sanford
uh long time frico camp uh member i
think he's at a coding bootcamp right
now too
um elliott says how are you able to cope
with being a parent and spouse
but also able to learn and work from
home
and what do you do to keep work from
taking over i'm struggling here
so balancing familial obligations with
um just uh work in general
and the diffuse nature of working from
home i should say yeah
i i mean we i'm i'm struggling with this
right because usually my kids are in
school
um and so it's been a month we've been
on lockdown here for a month
and at first i tried to like set the
kids up with their work
and work on my laptop by then but i
found that my children are i guess too
young they need more focused attention
so for me it's really about managing my
expectations
so part of the reason i'm a contractor
so i have free time
to work on side projects as you
mentioned earlier quincy someone said he
got laid off and he was going to start
building something that's amazing
and that's what i do for fun and i have
just accepted the fact that
until we're out of lockdown like i just
cannot do it i
just don't have time like i will lose my
sanity if i do it
i mean you know i have to let some do
you just have to let something go i
think and so
what we do here is i take the kids
except for today of course
i usually take the kids from 6 a.m to 1
p.m
and then my partner takes them in the
afternoon and then i supplement work in
the night
you know after hours as needed
but but it's hard and i think you know
we don't know how long this is going to
go on for
so i think it's it's really important to
although you have to work nights to
probably meet your deadlines and
continue your learning like
don't burn yourself out um try to
remember to take breaks
try to like block i think it's about
expectation management too
like if you're gonna do kids from six to
one like block out that time for them
and just accept
you're not gonna get any work done
during that time but
i mean i don't have a great solution
like i think you know i'm just figuring
it out
yeah how about you jessica
inter i know like how are you coping
with the balance the work-life balance
when
work and life are happening in the same
space
yeah i mean my husband i don't have kids
so i think that's
one i think big difference from my
situation
but i do know that when i first moved
from
working in a physical office to working
remotely that was like a huge transition
and
it honestly not to like scare people but
it probably took me a year before i felt
like comfortable and productive i was
just like supe
i felt very unproductive um and i felt
like
during work hours i would be distracted
and i wouldn't really
be able to focus on my work but then i
would have to catch up on my work
during the evening time when i should be
sort of relaxing and getting ready for
the next day so i think kind of what
colleen
was saying in terms of time blocking is
you know even if it's not nine to five
hours
try to when you're working be 100
working as much as possible of course
and then when you're not working try not
to let work sort of creep in
but even if you're catching up on your
work you know in the evening times i
think you can still
at least try to whatever current task
you're doing sort of try to stay focused
on that as much as you
as much as possible
yeah i can relate to that so um i had to
learn the same way like when i started
working
i was either totally unproductive or i
was working all the time
i kind of like juggled between the two
before i found a balance and what's been
interesting is that
like last month when i when my wife
started working from home
all of that balance kind of went out the
window and we had to discover it all
over again
and i saw her working all the time and i
was like what do i do so i also
like the options were look at twitter
look at the news
or lose yourself and work so i think the
first three weeks we just worked
like all day all night uh but recently
like
with finally like it took three weeks to
adjust but i think we found a balance
where uh we have a few things to work
like we have certain workers and then we
also know when to call it a day
and that's the funny thing with remote
like you don't see people walking out of
the office or you don't
like nobody tells you that it's time so
you kind of just have to
set a boundary for yourself and if
you're in the floor if you're dealing
with like a
bug that you just can't fix and you want
to get it done sometimes you just have
to say
it's 6 p.m i did what i could do today
i'm gonna try again tomorrow
and one thing that has really helped
with this which which is new to me like
i i did not do this earlier but it's new
now
which is i found these escapes right and
it can be like a productive escape
like a side project some started working
on a side project i'm super efficient
with that now
or it could be something which is not so
productive like playing animal crossing
right but just having something to look
forward to in the evening
like where you say like people talk
about blocking time for work
i started blocking time for not work so
like three hours in the evening i'm
either going to work on my side project
or play video game
and because i'm looking forward to that
i'm more motivated to finish my work
during the day so that we can you know
do stuff do something in the evening
like we've been so many shows on netflix
and
it's it's fine like that's what helps
the rest get done
exactly my pet is super happy right now
i'm spending more time with my cat
taking her to walk so it's like no
lockdown for her but it's locked down
for me
so yeah uh developers uh need to uh
utilize this time that they have got uh
and then they
make best use of it and also balance it
out between work and
the home life
right yeah and let's talk about time
and the temporality of working from home
because
a lot of if you're no longer in an
office you're no longer
like how many of your meetings are
synchronous where you're all talking
like at the same time uh where you have
like a scheduled meeting
like what percentage of your day would
you say is is actually
has to be a tackled at a specific time
versus like just
an open-ended block of time that you
could potentially shift to nighttime
when your kids are asleep for example
or other times like uh
yeah we'll start with you uh
colleen like what percentage of your
day is strictly regimented
to specific times um very little in
terms of my work like we have
um you know so most of my co-workers on
for this team i'm on now are on the west
coast
um so i prefer to you know kind of it
works better for me to work later hours
but we're completely asynchronous with
slack
so um i'm totally flexible there
okay and how about you um jessica
most yeah most of the communication with
my team is probably asynchronous as well
but there are
i do have a few meetings per week where
we try to be
it has to be everybody at the same time
but we're in relatively all the same
time zones so it's not too much of a
problem
yeah and instead with uh yeah i mean how
big is the code sandbox team because i
talked to the founder of
sandbox like a year or two ago and it's
grown so much
yeah i mean i mean so much is relative i
think when you talked was four people
now it's nine but still a pretty tiny
team
uh what's been interesting is that we do
the we do a daily stand up every day
i've done it since the start and it's
one of those like it's super optional oh
i love this
this reminds me of super famous kid
walking
sorry i knew this was going to happen
that we just moved into a new place and
that door doesn't lie
did you find this
hang on it's very appropriate this is
what we're all living with right now
okay this is real life
yep okay he's gonna hang out he's not
gonna touch the keyboard or anything
um he'll just be here for a few minutes
until he's bored
okay so um sorry for the interruption i
i anticipated that might happen my wife
has been kind of like on standby
to prevent that but the kids are very
wily
it's very welcome i've met like my in my
team i've met all the kids
all the pets i think this is like if a
cat comes crawling here you just let it
be
it's fine this is part of the part of
your team now
yeah yes i was talking about the stand
up so we decided
a long back like a while back they'd do
a daily stand up and it wasn't so much
to sync up on work
it was mostly to see each other's faces
and
now more than ever that's been really
useful that i think we've increased
our meetings now because it just kind of
helps to pair on something
like we had so many meetings where we
just spare even if it's like
anyone can solve the problem we would
just pair to do it together
because it's like a it's like a reminder
that we work together
and honestly it's kind of nice to fade
into like api details
and not worry about like the looming
thing in the background of your head
yeah and we have a question from the
chat for you sid uh
uh leonardo uh gallante is asking
uh what is the pair programming tool
that you all use currently
um so we use code sandbox uh paired with
tuple tuple
okay cool and code sandbox of course i
think
does it support multiple people editing
uh
a sandbox at the same time yeah you can
invite someone and then do the
dual cursor thingy yeah yeah so
your whole team remote
okay i mean there are three people in
amsterdam but then
right yeah so you're able to dog food
your own product dog fooding being like
you eat your own dog food
you're able to use code sandbox to work
on code sandbox
yep yep that's so matter
it gets hard sometimes yeah
all right so what advice do you have for
companies who are
uh trying to get used to this work from
home environment so
as said you have spoken about stand-ups
so how can companies effectively do
stand-ups
should it be like 15 minutes 45 minutes
one hour two hours
because i have heard companies staying
online and coding live
so is that the right thing or what is
the right thing here
i i can start so yeah i don't think
there's any right or wrong per se
right like i think like stand-ups are
great to just get everyone in the room
uh where stand-ups i've seen gone wrong
is where
you just start trying to solve problems
in the stand of itself
right right it's nice to just catch up
with everyone which for us with like
super tiny so it takes 10 minutes
but like depending on how many people in
the room you can go on for like 20-25
minutes
uh but then what's useful is that you
don't try to do things there
and instead break out into different
rooms so a lot of times our standups end
with somebody saying
somebody asking the other person to stay
back because they have a question for
them
and everyone else just says buys and
goes away and the
two people stay on for the call for
longer
yes how about you jessica
um yeah i mean i think this is one of
those questions where the
the correct answer is it depends but you
know i think
um yeah i think just trying to
effectively and efficiently run your
meetings whether they're in person or
online is really important because you
know if you have a
giant zoom call with like 25 people i
think you may not be able to be as
productive as you could if you
you know um split up into different
rooms
and also maybe being mindful of the the
amount of bandwidth that's available for
zoom worldwide and other places
so yeah
yeah and colleen did you have anything
you wanted to add on this
oh right i believe in over communication
in this situation
um now our team has always been remote
but like
i i liked i love sid actually i love the
idea of a daily 10 minute stand up
because i'm an extrovert and like i've
been in this house for four weeks
so i'm like talk to me someone talk to
me um
so i love that but uh we're trying to
move towards
more towards a more communicative model
because we've just i mean we also have a
really small team
and the code base is small so we're like
stepping on each other's toes sometimes
if we don't communicate enough
um so i just think it's a situation
where you over communicate i love the
daily stand-up idea i'm gonna
suggest that to the guys i work with and
um you know the the slack messages and
just
just a lot of communication because
you're not there you can't go look over
someone's shoulder and be like oh
you're working on this i'm working on
the same thing well that's you know
project management so
so how frequently do you think companies
should uh
discuss um their updates with the
developers like
in a day like is stand-up the only thing
like
calling like how what process do you
follow in your company
like do they meet multiple times in a
day or do they meet twice
like in the in the morning or and once
in the by the end of the day
so we don't do daily meetings um we just
do all our communication on trello
and slack and a call like if necessary
um but i like i said i would actually
i'm actually going to push to do a
little bit more because i think
it's hard to manage you know you guys
know like you have github issues you got
trello issues you got jira who knows
where yours are
so i i think it's better i mean i think
like
maybe even a daily like we don't have a
um someone that is just a program
manager
so everyone manages their own issues and
so
we only have we have maybe like priority
issues once a week where we get together
and talk about like is the priority
still the same coming from the customer
um so that's kind of what we've been
doing
great yeah and as far as uh
like physical space so i know you all
are working
from home uh in some cities people are
fortunate enough to be able to
have like multi-room setups i used to
live in san francisco and we lived
in a uh and like maybe 700 square feet
with uh
with the two year with the little baby
and it was uh
i can only imagine what it's like to be
going through that sort of situation
right now during the pandemic hit the
pandemic just
had the dice rolled differently in the
pandemic hit when i was still living in
there my life would be very
different from being in kind of a texas
standard
issue house but uh
but for for those of you who do have you
know more than one room or
different spaces around the house do you
delegate a specific room for like okay
i'm in work mode
now uh and how do you
go about deciding which space to use for
what and
do you have any hard and fast rules that
you apply
for that sure yeah
i mean i i also am fortunate to live in
a relatively low
cost of living part of the country and
so i do have a dedicated office which
i'm
extremely fortunate to have so
yeah as much as possible i try to limit
myself
you know in the physical space to just
do work in the office so like i'll
i'll never do work on my couch or in my
bed
of course part of that's probably
because i have an external monitor that
i'm completely addicted to
but you know i think i think it is
important to you know
if you're working from home keep have a
dedicated area even if it's just like
your dining table
um during certain parts of the day
dedicated to work
yeah that that's been interesting so
like this room is
was used to be my office and i i'm the
same like i've been lucky enough that i
was already set up for this
so i didn't have to change much what's
different is that now this is also my
wife's office
right so then we have to take turns so
now the dining table has kind of become
the other office and the couch in this
room has become where we have dinner
right so it kind of had to repurpose the
house because it's either the dining
table or the bed
and i know i'm not going to get anything
done from the bed
it's like the dining table is the office
desk now
and the couch is where we have our
dinner so you have to like
change it up a little but i think like
just just
defining those spaces was really helpful
um because it takes a while like it took
us two weeks but now we're
now i sit on the dining table and i know
it's the place where i work
and not where i eat food uh right so
that helps me get into the
zone as well right so one question
uh that somebody has asked me on twitter
is uh
what do you think that companies are
actually cautious about their ip being
late
uh their ideas been leaked because as
cities said like you and your wife are
working in two different companies
and uh so the projects that you are
working on so how do
how how should developers manage this
like
how can they take care of this thing
because sometimes companies
are very cautious about their ideas
their projects that they're currently
working on
should not be linked to others so what
do you have to say about that
are they inspired about leaking by like
someone talking to their friend about
the project or is it more like a
security like a hack
type i don't know just the idea being
discussed with someone else or
a person from another company
yeah so i guess a lot of discussions
might have previously taken place in
secure rooms especially like
you know colleen mentioned she was in
defense and i imagine they have all
kinds of additional layers of security
there
but uh if if you're at home there could
be like an alexa unit
that's just passively listening and we
don't know like
whether that is actually being
transcribed somewhere uh same thing with
like people's phones and stuff like all
the traditional
security when you're on a meeting you
know things could be said that
uh could be recorded somewhere else or
people could hear about
or if you and your spouse are in the
same industry then
you know competitive information might
inadvertently be shared
that uh you know so i guess i'm not sure
if this affects any of you all
but uh do do your companies have any
sort of policies or are they
even thinking about these things at this
point i imagine there are lots of other
things they're thinking about
[Music]
i mean i i guess it's brave to assume
that
my wife already doesn't know everything
about my work
[Laughter]
like being at home it doesn't really
give an advantage but i do understand
where the question is coming from so
like uh before this
like a long time ago i used to work for
a healthcare startup
and there were a bunch of rules about uh
personal information like health data is
kind of like very private and stuff
so uh just for like for checking off all
the
things in the security audit we were
supposed to have
uh like what we call fingerprint
scanners in the office and you weren't
allowed to take any hardware outside of
the office
so like a bunch of rules and i imagine
any company that
requires you to like log in from a
certain terminal
all of that now is up up in the air
right you work with whatever thing you
have at home
and like i like if i was still at
zero maybe they would have a very good
answer because they kind of are a
security company
but with code sandbox like the more we
do in the open the better it is for us
so
i it's something that i've just like
forgotten about
yeah well let's talk about let's move to
the staying sane part
uh of working from home productively
because i think
it's clear that you all are working
productively it sounds like
things are still getting done most of
you were already working from home
before so it's just
the same routine probably just
compressed time i would imagine
with uh other responsibilities and also
i guess one question is like a lot of
you have colleagues who weren't working
from home
uh and now they are and suddenly they're
having to rapidly
spool up on what you all had already
kind of intuited
about successfully working from home
what would be your advice to your
colleagues
uh and have you given any advice to
colleagues or that who've approached you
and said like oh i know you work from
home like how can i do this
right like what would be your quick and
dirty tips
uh for successfully working from home if
a colleague approached you and asked you
colleen so i have a lot of tips
because i feel like jessica it took me
maybe a year to kind of like figure this
out
um so i think you have to remember to
we're in the middle of a pandemic so as
we discussed at the beginning of this
your mental and emotional state aren't
going to be what they would be otherwise
so you need to be mindful of that but
like practical tips are this
um you're at home so you don't have the
natural breaks that
you would have in an office so do a
pomodoro timer
um you can actually see my yoga mat
behind me because i do 25 minutes of
work and then five minutes of stretching
um and i do that all day but um i would
recommend that to force breaks first
give your eyes a break
just give yourself a little break i also
recommend during that time do not get on
social media because that will distract
your brain
from whatever you were working on before
so i like to take those five minutes of
break time
and like i said like do yoga or you know
throw a load of laundry in or something
like that
um and then the time blocking we talked
about earlier i thought
was um was really good that really helps
and then so what i do
kind of like the office i also have an
office and i use my noise cancelling
headphones like you guys have on
and that kind of puts me in like the
mental work state like when i even
though i don't always turn them on
like if they're on my ears like i know
i'm supposed to be working
so i think actually someone in the last
chat talked about
atomic habits but um james clear talks
about that in his book is having these
habit cues
and so for me one of my habit cues is
noise canceling headphones so that
really helps
okay awesome noise cancelling headphones
pomodoro technique
um having something you can do during
that that uh
break time during the pomodoro to and
and staying away from social media
during breaks because
you know for the second you glance at
twitter trending it's just it's all over
like you're like what's that oh my gosh
is that really happening is is the real
world really this horrible
now um how about you jessica what would
you
how would you advise a colleague who
just realized that they have to work
from home
for the first time yeah i think i mean
colleen has some really excellent tips i
think just
to add to that i'd say maybe one is take
breaks like i tried to get out of the
house and take a
brief walk a couple times a day
obviously you know following whatever
guidelines are in place for where you
live
and i think it's really hard for people
who
were working in a physical office up
until recently to
feel connected especially if you're more
on the extroverted side
so one thing that i've been doing with
colleagues is actually doing zoom
meetings just to kind of catch up so
like we'll do like a virtual coffee
break a couple times a week
if any of you have played jack box it's
like a game you can play over zoom
relatively easily if you share your
screen just like a group game everyone
plays
um on their phone and so it's just kind
of a fun way to
have a little break in the day kind of
get maybe some of that energy
the social energy back
okay great um and
uh how about you sid yeah what advice
would you have for a colleague
everything jessica and coin said uh the
only thing i'd add
is like first of all i really like what
jessica said
because it's something that i have
started doing too
and it's like i'm not extroverted
but this is also not my happy place
right
like even as an introvert being logged
in your house is not what introverts
want
right like i i like the choice of going
to a party i just don't like going to
parties
right but what i've like
what i've been enjoying which is new for
me is exactly what she said just calling
up your
coworkers just to have a chat which is
not about work right just asking them
how they're holding up what are they up
to and just just the fact that we're all
doing this together at the same time
kind of
takes away a lot of guilt that i get for
like not being efficient or not working
and i think more than like getting the
work done getting away from the guilt
has been really helpful for me
and that kind of motivates me to get
back to work
uh practical tips what i like is like
i'm kind of obsessed with blocking time
so like early in the morning or like the
night before i'll plan out
what do i want to do the next day and
then in the morning
i'll just have blocks of time like this
is this is when i make lunch
right this is when my meeting is this is
what i try to get done and then
just making sure i have at least a few
giant
chunks of time where i can actually
write code uh
is is kind of crucial for me and
the the last thing i would add is having
like a
ritual almost like a habit thing like we
we think that we can
hustle our way through this right like
we all we lack is motivation to work
it honestly like our brains are stupider
than that so we really have to like
pull them into it so i really like
having like a
morning start work routine where it's
like i open a notepad i look at my tasks
and i just write for 15 minutes and that
kind of gets me in the
in the headspace to start work instead
of you know
thinking about twitter or recently
thinking about tick tock because that's
what it has come to
and in the you know i i i started by
like taking a walk so this was like my
pre uh
lockdown routine where i would just to
end work i would go for a 15 minute work
now that 15 minute has become i just
like stretch
on or do some exercise on my wife's yoga
mat so it's like
just having these tiny events or like
tiny
actions that kind of say like okay this
ends my work day and now i'm ready for
like
the other stuff has kind of been useful
to
fool my brain into it like stop thinking
about work start thinking about your
wife now
right on well one thing that i think we
would be remiss not to cover is
how is this pandemic going to affect the
future of work
um how is this experience of social
distancing
and basically all of us working
from home during this period like do you
think that people are going to go back
to
offices everything's just going to go
back to normal and snap back
the moment that a vaccine comes out and
is widely available and we're all safely
able to just return to the office
like do you think that that is going to
happen or do you think that this is
going to cause some permanent waves
well i think it will cause permanent
waves because i
think without a pandemic generally
obviously depends on the person but
working from home is just
so much better so you know i'm in this
social slack group with some friends and
one of the guys
is disabled and he's been telling he was
telling us like for years he's a web
developer
for years company with companies
wouldn't hire him because they said
you can't work remotely and now surprise
everyone can work remotely
so you know that's frustrating for him
but he's also he also thinks it's
wonderful because he's like the whole
disabled
tech community now has been given more
opportunities to work from home
something they were told they couldn't
do
um and i mean i think for everyone most
people again
remote work is just it's just better so
i think a lot of people are gonna push
to keep it
if they can and it's cheaper for the
company right like office space in
manhattan
you know
right many developers are going to
realize that they are actually more
productive now
and hopefully after the lockdown they
are going to
request their employers to like allow
them to work from home
yeah i think so i'm kind of like
double minded on that because i think a
lot of developers would
like it because it kind of takes away
the skepticism they had
right like i've talked to a bunch of
friends who said this would never work
right
or they're like no i'm an extrovert i
need people around me
but now that they're forced into it they
were forced to also look at the good
sides along with the bad side
so i have a feeling like at least a
bunch of developers would want to do it
yes i'm also afraid that a lot of
like higher ups in the team right would
look at this and say we tried remote
work it wasn't as productive
right like this was this would be the
bad case study
yeah where the truth is like nobody is
productive right
so i think i think it would definitely
increase the number of chances
so if you're a company that can go
remote i think you'll just
there would be more demand for remote
work and you can just capitalize on that
by allowing people to work remotely and
your folks would like having the
choice i think would be the difference
yeah
so i have a question for you guys for uh
do you guys have people
in an office anywhere press both for sid
and jessica
are you is your company fully remote
because i always have i have this theory
that a pack of people are in the office
and you're remote then it's bad for the
remote person and i'm wondering if
that's true
right i think it depends on the company
uh my company is
majority in office so i was working
remotely
even before i am a minority but um
i think that it really depends on the
company they've done just such a great
job of
making remote remote employees feel on
the same level as like the in person
obviously you know we miss out on some
of the water cooler chat and some other
you know talking about projects that
might come up but for the most part
it's been done well so i think it may
depend on the company
yeah i can relate to that so i think it
depends on like how
how seriously does the company want to
take it so at odd zero i was working
with a
i want to say 13 our time difference um
like most of my team was in beyonce
cyrus in argentina
so even though they were all remote they
were kind of in the same time zone
um so what was interesting was
that the team kind of had a rule that if
they're having a
meeting with one person remote they'll
just go sit in different corners of the
office and all
join by a zoom so i think just having
it's like treating everyone as equal was
kind of the point and even if a decision
is made
in person where for example like a lot
of time people would meet in the office
when i'm just sleeping
but they'll make sure they document it
and they put it in a dock where we just
like chew on it for a while and comment
on it
to to get the conversation so i think a
lot of it is like
i'm sure a lot of companies are bad when
they start
and then they learn this through the
times and then like just having a mature
process
around it really helps uh right now at
code sandbox
we do have an office which is like it's
it's
we call it an office it's a room in a
co-working space right so
sometimes when we feel like seeing each
other's faces we just end up going there
so like we have three people in
amsterdam including me
so we end up meeting each other once a
week and then
uh every month one or two people
from around europe just like flies in to
spend some time in the office
and that's more of like a social thing
than uh it's like
like there are there are co-workers that
i've never met in person
which kind of feels weird so this helps
that once in a while you just get to sit
next to them
and you know i don't know look at look
that they actually have legs
an artist
just an insight from chat jesse weigel a
frequent uh youtube streamer here on the
free code game channel on a prolific
dev he said uh he often feels that uh
it's difficult to participate in a
meeting when he's working remotely
and everybody else is in an office and
and
being the remote person is kind of like
you're you're the outsider and there
have been studies conducted
i think stanford did a study of remote
work in china and they found that it's
harder to get
like you're just as productive as
everybody else or maybe more productive
because you don't have to spend a lot of
time commuting
but uh you are less likely to be
promoted because
the work you're doing isn't as visible
as the people in the office
so we could talk about this for another
hour uh this has been fantastic i've
learned so much
i've gotten so much insight and i i
think it's going to change how i
personally work from home
especially a lot of the insights i've
gotten you know from uh
from colleen who's done this for so long
and it's great hearing how
uh how sid and how um
jessica's organizations are approaching
this as well
this is almost a reckoning for everybody
who is previously like
uh not working remotely and working with
other people remotely now
there's gonna be a lot more empathy i
think going forward when they're working
with colleagues who work from home
because
hey everybody's gonna have had that
experience
right it'll be it'll be kind of a
permanent uh memory
uh that will persist and hopefully
you know make people more empathetic
going forward so
um i'm hopeful that that is one silver
lining that will come out of this
i just want to thank you all uh all
three of you for coming on
it's been phenomenal uh as i said i've
learned so much i've been sharing some
insights in chat
and over on twitter and everybody who's
watching this
and hears like a you know a really
compelling thing
like the point colleen made about people
who were previously
told they couldn't get a job because
they couldn't work remotely because you
can't work remotely
if you're if you have a disability that
requires you to stay home hey
like there's a proof of concept now that
work can be done remotely so therefore
hopefully this is you know a huge boon
to
people in the disabled community who are
who are interested in uh
getting more job opportunities so yeah
there's a silver lining to every cloud
even a cloud is as black as this one
so again i want to thank you very much
uh
jessica colleen sid everybody scroll
down
click on their twitter follow these
people on twitter they're fantastic i
don't regret it all following them i've
learned so much from them
and be sure to check out jessica's uh
fantastic
instagram thank you everybody
we'll be right back in about 10 minutes
everybody stay tuned
and uh just keep each other company in
chat cheers
thank you we are going to be talking all
about
the post coronavirus pandemic uh
developer job market essentially
uh what you need to do to be able to
get a job during this pandemic uh what
your prospects are
uh how you might want to change your
approach um
and like what your odds are who's
actually still hiring
what kind of organizations are likely to
grow during this period
where opportunities are going to come
from we're gonna be talking about all
those things and more and i
am very proud to have gotten three
amazing guests who all know quite a bit
about this
domain um first
aileen lerner learner she
is extremely learned as her last name
may suggest
she studied at mit and is an engineer
and
a developer and she also worked as a
recruiter
and she was unsatisfied with the way
uh technical recruiting worked
and she founded a company called
interviewing.io where you can go
and you can get uh interview training
and you can work with real
people to get uh interviewed and you can
get a job through there too
and maybe she can share some statistics
about like the number of people who've
gone through it later
but uh we're we're thrilled to have you
with us thank you thank you
andrew brown uh from toronto uh
and he is a
super knowledgeable guy he's worked as a
developer for years and years and now
he runs exam pro dot co which is a
website where you can go to get
comprehensive aws certification training
and he's been working
on getting as many people as possible
through these certifications so they get
certified so they can get
the many many cloud engineer jobs that
are
out there and probably growing as a
result of this pandemic
um and so andrew brown thank you very
much for joining us
oh thank you and laurence bradford
uh you have probably heard her if you're
learning the code
uh learn to code with dot me is her
website it is an amazing website that
she
she's got a blog she's written a whole
lot actually everybody here i'll just
say
everybody here on this uh panel has
published extensively with free code
camp
so if they're if they seem familiar that
may be one of the reasons why alien
lerner has written extensively about
uh the job market and uh the technical
interview process and shared tons of
data that she's gotten from our platform
andrew has created uh at least three i
think
four major full-length courses that are
on free code camp's youtube channel
including an aws for startups and also
uh through three different aws
certifications and
laurence has done so many amazing
articles
on freecodecamp as well and she has
one of the longest running programming
related podcasts
out there it's the learn to code with me
podcast so uh
if you go into itunes or wherever you
listen to podcasts
just search learn to code with me and
you will find
her podcast and she has done 120
episodes she's she's getting ready to
head into i think season
uh season seven season seven okay
yeah so these people are extremely
prolific and knowledgeable and i'm super
excited to hear their insights
about the evolving job market so as i
started with the other panels i just
want to
it is strange to be talking about
opportunity
uh in a time of death
and despair and disease and i just want
to
emphasize that
we are aware of all these things
we are not physicians we're not front
line workers we're developers
we're all doing the best we can
we can take as a given that
life kind of sucks right now for a whole
lot of people
and we can be empathetic about that at
the same time
i'm optimistic that you know 12 18
months from now
there will be a widely available
vaccination and life will go back to
some semblance
of what it was before and this is a good
time for us to be thinking about that
and thinking about what the world might
look like coming out of that and also
figuring out what we can do today
to you know create a positive
influence on tomorrow so
i just want to say that right now it may
seem crass that we're talking very
uh transactionally very
bluntly about the developer ecosystem
and the job market and all those things
when people are out there
dying and i just want to say that
we we do care about that and we're aware
of those things but
we're gonna we're not doctors we're not
gonna give you any medical advice or
anything like that we're just gonna stay
focused on what we know
what we know is helping people advance
their developer careers
so thank you with that
note uh i want to go ahead and kick it
off and just
uh ask aileen how's everything going
with you
how's everything going with uh the
developer job ecosystem in general at a
very high level
in your in your thinking yeah um things
have changed
quickly in some ways and they've stayed
the same in others
so my my whole world is my company and
i'm very heads down in that but
fortunately what we do is very tied to
the subject we're talking about so i'll
just share what we've seen
and hopefully that's useful um as kind
of a microcosm of what's going on
everywhere everywhere else in the world
so um
interviewing io does two things we help
people prepare for technical interviews
and then if they do well regardless of
how they look on paper
we actually let them skip a lot of the
stuff that happens at the top of the
funnel like applying online or talking
to recruiters
and they can like directly book
technical interviews with engineers at
companies where they might want to work
so what is uh what are the implications
of that
um on one hand uh we've seen a lot more
engagement
among our existing users right so i
think people are
home now more than they used to be which
means they don't have to go hide in a
conference room
to do an interview during the work day
so we're seeing people interviewing
a lot more which also means there's more
competition for potentially a smaller
number of jobs i'll get to that in a
moment
we've also seen and i'll just be
transparent about this um
a good chunk of our customers freeze
hiring
and it's sort of it kind of came in this
sort of um
uh normal distribution like at first it
was this trickle
right and people are like yeah we're
just going to freeze for a week
everything's fine and then
you know a few days later no it's we're
going to freeze for like two or three
weeks and then more and more customers
came in and started freezing
um those tended to be if we were to put
a category there
companies that are probably series a and
um
earlier so those companies i think are
the ones that tend to have
the most uncertainty and the most
instability and
in some cases less runway so of course
it makes sense that they're being
conservative
some of our larger customers we've seen
pick up on hiring
i think in part it's a response to the
increased inbound
applications that they're getting and in
part i think it's because
unless they're very very stable right
let's say you're a series b
series c type company right you're
probably going to start seeing a little
more attrition
right now because some portion of your
engineers
are going to proactively go to the most
stable jobs of all which is
probably fang right facebook um apple
amazon
netflix google and microsoft potentially
um
so uh we we have seen a shift to more
people applying there
but we have seen a pickup in hiring
especially among
these sort of larger companies that are
doing things that are
in some way uh related to solving the
problems the world is facing right now
maybe it's remote communication right
maybe it's healthcare and healthcare is
a very big umbrella that covers a lot of
different things
but in general we've seen that that
space pick up um
maybe it's logistics right uh maybe it's
delivery of food
uh so there have been these sort of
spikes and then there's been
a lot of drops and i think net if we
were to average out the whole thing
there's definitely been a slowdown in
hiring um
but it doesn't we were expecting to see
maybe
you know half or more of our customers
freeze and that absolutely has not
happened and our overall
interview volume like how it's what it's
constituted of has shifted
but it actually hasn't dropped very much
okay great uh so just to be clear like
the number of opportunities may have
decreased but it's not nearly as big of
a decrease as you might think
yep and who knows i mean i don't know i
basically stopped trying to predict the
future right uh
things change so quickly like in a
matter of days and our strategy has
changed like three times internally now
so it's a hard time for us but
um so far it's less bad than i think
anybody internally thought it would be
okay awesome and uh alien if you could
just kind of hold your mic slightly off
your shirt it's just
it's pushing your mic which is creating
a little bit of clicking so exactly yeah
no worries i didn't want to like ruin
your flow or anything
yeah just when you're talking and you
can just me when you're not talking so
you don't have to worry about it but
that's like a
frequent thing i'm sure laurence has
encountered that when she's doing
podcasts like the
i do the apple headphones always had the
mic rub against the shirt collar i get
very animated
also like if you have jewelry on i i do
this like sometimes it can bang against
the table
and i realize that i'm like oh i'm
probably so loud like right near the
microphone but yeah
yeah well laurence uh so you're
experiencing this from
from a different perspective you have
tons of friends who are applying for
jobs
uh what has your experience been like
anecdotally
yeah so my experience is really
different because i'm not
um working with directly people who are
applying to different companies i'm not
working with companies who are
interviewing candidates but i've been
hearing
from friends and also just my own
research honestly the last few weeks
i don't i don't know why but i've been
very into following
who's hiring who's laying off um like
these shifts and where like people are
spending money the new york times
actually published a really interesting
graphic yesterday that
showed it was like this really just bar
chart that showed where people are
spending less
concerts uh restaurants a few other
things that just like aren't really a
reality right now when we can't go
outside and be in groups
but then it showed this like spike in
spending in other areas like delivery
services
groceries i mean i know personally as a
household we spent twice as much last
month
on groceries like going to the grocery
store buying food or delivery stuff
than we did the month prior and i'm so
yeah i've just been fascinated with this
shift and like where we're spending
money how we're spending money the
company's laying off the companies who
are hiring more now
and as you said quincy i've had friends
who have been laid off
or on the other hand friends that are
completely overwhelmed and really
stressed out with work right now because
they're having the most work that
they've ever had in their life and
specifically the two friends i'm
thinking of work in like
shipping logistics e-commerce
uh my my like childhood best friend
growing up
she she doesn't work in tech but she
works in like shipping logistics for dhl
which is a really big like shipping
company and she has huge clients all
around the globe and she's like
this has been the craziest week i've
worked here for five years and this
the craziest few weeks has been
absolutely insane but
turning the conversation like back
towards technology
i've been really following a lot of the
news again of the companies that
are laying people off which there are a
lot i feel like if you look at the
headlines or you turn on cnn or what
have you
another company is laying people off and
other companies laying people off but
then
on the flip side there are a lot of
companies that are increasing hiring
another friend of mine who used to work
at a
cannabis startup of sorts i don't know
exactly what
they did but i know she got laid off and
i know she
very quickly got an interview at a
life insurance company because it's not
really shocking but life insurance sales
i think
they've doubled or something since all
the coronavirus stuff has been happening
so there are these industries that maybe
isn't talked about as much that are
seeing an increase in demand because of
all this
um and as you said in the beginning
quincy like
it is really unfortunate that so many
companies are going under or laying
people off
and then there are like these winners
and losers but it just is
i don't know the way it is right now
yeah and andrew what's your experience
you're you're coming to us from uh
north of the border uh yeah yeah
i can give you the canadian experience
and i do know a little bit that's going
on uh to our our friends to the south
um and i would i would agree with
laurence um there are industries that
are
definitely taking off and ones that
aren't i can specifically say like if
you're looking at edtech
med tech or stream tech uh those ones
we're seeing
uh that they're uh that they're thriving
because they're going virtual or you
know it's direct to the pandemic
or the fact that everybody has to uh now
uh work virtually
um other industries that uh the
technical demand is growing i wouldn't
say they're thriving but
the demand is there is insure tax so
lauren's just mentioned that that's a
really good
uh point and delivery tech that's
another one right how to get stuff to
people or logistics
uh so you know if you are looking for a
job uh you know
consider looking at those industries and
trying to tailor
tell your resume or tailor your skills
for these industries in the short term
because i think that's going to help you
um to talk specifically about the roles
that we're seeing that people are
getting laid off for for those who don't
know like um
you know i wasn't just a developer i was
a cto um for multiple startups prior
and so i'm very fortunate to be part of
a network of ctos in canada
and so when people say that um that
company's laying them off
i literally see the ctos in a slack
group saying i had to lay off these
people
and then what they're doing is they are
trying to
mitigate that by helping um uh or
finding other companies to help
hire these people back okay um but to
talk specifically about the actual roles
where i'm seeing
um that are being de-prioritized and the
ones that are now
scaling up on i actually made a little
list here so there's
there's uh what i've been seeing for
people getting let go for is
sales and business development digital
marketing ux and web design
uh in some cases uh uh data analysis
uh and that's why i like to think of it
as that there's growth aesthetics and
uh and uh analysis which are being cut
down on
because that's really when you're
focusing on the growth of your business
and right now people are being more
conservative
and so they're looking more for security
reliability and support
and for those kind of roles we're seeing
a huge increase in
a general technologist if we're talking
about from the cloud perspective that's
called a solution
architect uh project management's very
important uh cloud engineer so that's a
hybrid between web developer and cloud
skills
virtual assistants i even have to get a
virtual assistant because the increase
in this this market has been uh crazy
social media support so we might have
seen a decrease in people doing sales
and marketing but we're seeing an
increase in support
uh for uh existing users uh and that
stuff like that
data engineers so we saw a drop with um
data analysis but we're seeing now data
engineers will become more popular
site reliability officer that's someone
that makes sure that
the platform is running uh stable and
security engineers
so you know listen to that uh that list
i gave you i might share it uh later on
into the free code camp discord as a
as a conversation after after there if
you want to know a little bit more about
those roles
but that is my take on it and that's me
looking at these lists
that are coming in who's getting laid
off and that stuff and by the way
uh these lists are actually public um i
just don't feel like they're publicized
very well
and so i was able to grab those links
and i have a list of lists
of places that are are are hiring and a
list of lists that are layoffs and you
can go through there and you can see
what's being hired for and what's not
and there's another list of
of of people that are getting uh that
are
looking for work right it's called the
helpless dot ca um
and i i think there's other countries
doing it i just know i just know the
canadian space
um uh but but you look at those lists
and and you can even get a feel of you
know how you can align to that market to
get a job
uh so you know there i think that's a uh
a bit for now so
i'll tell you yeah i mean that in the
background fantastic and
it sounds like you have the making of
like a big you know
like a major article like or maybe even
a regular article like hey
here like this this week's update uh
during the uh
uh pandemic pandemic job status
anyway any way i could help i'd love to
write an article it's just it's people
just have to ask me right
so yeah right yeah well consider this a
request for
there you go then you get and you'll get
an article and laurence i know
you've also been trying to assemble as
much information as you can
and get it out there in the hands of
people as far as like uh
i mean we could we could absolutely run
like some sort of survey or something
i should actually put together a survey
for this conference
sorry i didn't think about that until
now uh
but i will i'll get that together and
i'll shoot that link out through twitter
so just
follow the lockdown conf hashtag and
look for a post conference survey
a lot of people are watching live right
now we're getting some questions i'll go
to those in a moment thank you everybody
for asking your questions
please just pile all your questions in
there uh we've got
experts for the next uh 30 minutes or so
and we want to get as many other
questions to them as as we can
and then a huge number of people
probably like 90 of the people
who are going to watch this are going to
watch this after the stream ends and
just watch the uh
you know the the edited version where
we're going to edit out the breaks and
everything but um so
uh i have a very very quick
um question that i think
uh i want to ask
to mike omc um
how are things going in bangalore and
what's the indian experience like
because india
is a massive country with tons of tech
companies and
i just heard that the uh lockdown was
further extended
today yeah yeah yeah the lockdown has
been extended
uh yeah the lockdown has been extended
till may 3rd uh we just got news
from the prime minister this morning and
uh
the companies are taking it slow here uh
from what i have heard
uh most of the companies
like food delivery companies and
hyper local markets and all those
companies have reduced the number of
hiring here
at that in the current time and
most of the uh hiring that are going on
as andrew said
are on the non-technical uh
jobs right now so
so yeah um it's uh it
hasn't impacted um like some
anything different from the rest of the
world
okay great and uh this question comes
from
the audience uh from elliot sanford who
as i mentioned earlier we had a question
from him
uh he is a boot camp student and he's
getting ready to graduate it's kind of
like the
university graduate in 2008 right like
coming out to a fairly tepid job market
a relatively tepid market
coming out of a coding bootcamp in 2020
uh what would be uh his question is how
should i
as a bootcamper near graduation combat
negativity
and what things can i do to compete
against the more experienced developers
in the hiring pool uh
i'll start great yeah um
so there are two things that make coming
out of a boot camp really hard
and i think these things were always
hard even in a great market and they're
going to be extra hard
now so the first thing is even getting
your foot in the door
so as you probably know there is a
somewhat potentially unfair bias against
boot camp grads
and what makes it even harder now is
that
one of the other groups that we haven't
talked about who's experiencing heavy
layoffs
is recruiters so recruiters are getting
laid off like crazy which means that a
company that previously
potentially had a whole team dealing
with junior hiring
might now have just a handful of people
that are scattered between
sales recruiting ops recruiting um and
engineering recruiting
and some of them might not be domain
experts in those fields because they're
just being
grabbed and that's what they're doing
now um so
it's even more important now than it
ever was before
to find a way to get noticed and stand
out and
if you apply online and i've said this
before about applying online even in the
best situations it's kind of like
screaming into a black hole
like the abyss will probably not answer
you uh
so if you can um just bypass recruiting
entirely
find an engineer that works at that
company find somebody even if you don't
know them maybe they wrote a blog post
about something you're interested in
just
get on hacker news get on the company
blog get on linkedin
make a list of engineers that work there
that you have something
smart you can say to or something that
you uh can talk about a shared interest
you know maybe maybe you know somebody
in common
and just treat it like a sales job so
pretend you're a
sales development representative and you
have a funnel
and it's your job to just reach out to
engineers
at a bunch of companies that you want to
work and to each one
say something that doesn't just say hey
i graduated from a bootcamp and i'm
looking for a job
talk about something they've done you're
interested in talk about something
you've done
that is related to the subject matter
and you're going to get a lot of
you're not even going to get rejections
most people will just ignore you but
this will probably improve your odds of
getting noticed by an order of magnitude
if not more so that's the first thing
the second thing that makes graduating
from a boot camp really hard
is being prepared for technical
interviews
now different companies interview
differently not everybody does
full-on algorithmic interviews but
depending on where you're applying
chances are they do and you can probably
find out one of my
personal biggest pet peeves with i think
every boot camp
under the sun is that they do not do an
adequate job of preparing you for this
and they also de-emphasize how important
it is so i would get on
starting your funnel doing all your
outreach to everybody to get your foot
in the door
and in parallel i would start
heavily preparing for technical
interviews
codecamp has a free code camp has a lot
of resources of course
my company does this so we'll encourage
you to go to interviewing i o
but there are books there there are a
ton of resources out there um
and i would spend weeks if not months
and i'm sorry this this is going to
sound discouraging but
weeks if not months working algorithmic
problems
uh understanding data structures and
filling in those gaps
that your boot camp probably left in
your education it's going to be hard but
if you kind of
embrace the idea that it's going to be
hard and make peace with it
you'll be successful just sort of say
it's going to take three months for me
to find a job maybe more
i'm okay with it and in the meantime i'm
gonna go heads down and focus on these
two things
cool awesome advice and i'm actually
typing up verbatim a quote
you just said alien uh so uh andrew did
you want to talk about this a little bit
too
oh yeah i would love to talk about it so
it uh so for those who don't know i'm in
the
uh the greater toronto area and i
actually do a lot of mentorship with
bootcamp grads
from a variety of different ones here so
we have general assembly
lighthouse labs uh we cloud data
and juno and so there is a bit of a
difficulty getting the job
at the tail end there um the career
services for every boot camp is
different
some are some give you a lot of support
afterwards um some
uh put on you to to do that effort but i
can give you a couple of hacks of what
you could do
to try to get a job in the market um and
so there's there's two ways we can we
can take the friendly way or we can do
the cold call way
and so let's talk about the cold call
way um and this is my approach
and i could do this today and get a job
uh in a week
and so so this is what i would do i
would go to angel list
uh camera if it's dot say or whatever
the or dot io i feel like it's a dot io
but if you look up angel list it has all
the startups
uh in the world uh per country so i
would say okay what's my closest uh
tech hub it's toronto or what's in my
time zone
as long as it's my time zone or near me
that's great i'm going to sort by the
greenest greenest meaning the newest
startups on the market i'm going to go
down the list i'm going to try to guess
who
is near raising money to get uh
their their their it depends on what
kind of risk you want to take but if
you're
if they're close to getting their seed
or their series a i'm going to find
those green companies i'm going to look
at them and say
um what do they do and what impact can i
make on their company
and uh then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to reach out with them and i'm
actually going to build them something
and i'm just going to ship it to them
because if you show up and hand with
some something it's very hard for people
to say no if you can guess what it is
that's going to really help them
uh it's it's very unlikely they will
will turn you away
but i think it's a better method than
applying to 30 40 places
if you uh it's better to build 10 apps
that are for very specific industries
and then you get to keep those apps
and also um you get faster and faster
building applications so you say if you
think it takes a lot
a lot of time that is the number one
thing i find uh bootcamp grads coming
out of their curriculum is that
they do not have the the technical speed
um so they might have the skill but they
don't have the speed and so you should
be able to build out
uh small applications whether it's five
or ten
in a week and ship those things out and
you'll get a much greater response
and the thing is people are always
worried about giving those away for free
the reason i'm not worried about doing
it is that
if somebody wants to utilize it they
need the person that built it to
maintain it and you have them on the
hook
so they're going to want to bring you in
the door for that
you've really thought about what the
problem is for the business owner
and a lot of startups just do not post
their jobs online because they do not
have time
or uh there's such a small team it's
just like they feel like they're wasting
their time so they're gonna wait till
they get to a certain growth
before they post that stuff out and by
taking that initiative that is a great
way
to get your foot in the door and also to
get a role that you normally wouldn't be
able to get and then quickly move up the
ladder
okay so that is the cold call way the
other way is the friendly way and i find
this works for
medium to large companies and the idea
is that you want to become friends
with whoever it is uh that works for
that company so if you want to work at
aws
you better go on linkedin you better add
everybody you know that works at aws
um and and be authentic and and try to
be as helpful as you can and document
your journey
that is parallel to this company and uh
you know hopefully what they'll do is
they'll take notice of
uh of it they'll like your stuff i never
tell people to go message people
directly on linkedin i say go add
somebody
you don't have to message them and then
just if they'll see if you're active
they'll see you in their stream if
they're interacting with you that means
they're aware of your content
and then you can go reach out or you can
go on linkedin say
boy i wish i had a job like this and
those people who've already seen it and
then they'll reach out to you
um and and that's the friendly canadian
way to get a job i don't know if it
works everywhere but it definitely works
really well here
uh so those are my two hacks for you one
thing i'll quickly add if that's okay
i strongly advise not messaging
engineers on linkedin or adding them on
linkedin because they're not
they hate it because all they ever get
there is recruiter spam right so
sorry so i would say that in context it
depends what it is so if you want to add
engineers
just add them if your profile looks and
by the way i have an article
i think called linkedin for losers i
don't know why i named it that but
because
it's like ll but i i agree with you i
think you're right i get so much spam it
drives me crazy
but if you just add somebody what
they're going to do is they're going to
look at your linkedin profile they're
going to say
what is this person's motivation what
why do they want to connect with
with me and if you look like that you
just you're interested in the same space
and you're going to share cool content
and you're not going to be like
like spamming that person trying to get
a job then they're going to add you
and then down the road when you build up
that friendship then you can message
them
or or do that subtle thing saying oh boy
i wish i could work here
yeah um i guess both approaches can work
i in my experience i found that just
figuring out somebody's email address
and writing them a highly personalized
email
that touches on something they've done
before and something you're interested
in
is much more effective but i uh i have
not tried
uh sort of the add me and then i'm gonna
post interest well i'll tell you
i'll tell you the other day i got an
email from somebody and and they sent me
a really long email and it was great
but uh it was so long and especially
like when you're uh like a developer
you're busy
you don't have time to read long emails
and your brain just turns off so if you
do want to take that approach
make sure it's concise but the only
reason i stuck with that email was
because
the person who sent me the email their
profile was was star trek themed
so they said so that is a big long thing
and i'm going to read this going
oh man they're just trying to they're
just trying to like uh uh
uh game me you know like trying to
trying to uh
build that relationship really fast um
but that they had that that uh
personal biased uh and that that got
them a personal response back for me
i wouldn't say uh that always works
every single time but it just that time
it worked
so yeah personalization is key i've
gotten so many emails where people just
rehash everything they've ever done and
it just reads like a generic cover
letter
i get dozens of those a day and i tend
to ignore them
i would say oh sorry about that i would
say um i would say that
it's not just being personable it's
being authentic and i think as humans
we can tell when something is off so so
even if you think you're being
personable it's like we know you're up
to something right so
personal so something that touches on
something you've done something i've
done something that
not just friendly but something that
that draws on a shared interest or or
something useful that isn't just
networking i think we're saying the same
thing oh you don't know
for certainly i'm just i'm just trying
to to iterate that uh
being personable is not the same thing
as being authentic
totally and i think that you know you
can be personable but we're like okay
great but we see that there's an agenda
behind it
um and you know and i get just to
interrupt like i get a lot of emails
uh and a lot of them address me as sir
like sir
and i immediately know okay this
person's probably asking for something
if they're
calling me sir right off the bat if
that's how they address me uh and also
if i get an email from you and it's in a
like a non-plain text font
i'm just gonna automatically archive it
like i won't read it because
the quality of the emails that i get
that are not in like just the standard
text that have some sort of
formatting on them is always very low uh
so it's just like pattern recognition
don't use funky fonts don't use like a
lengthy signature
um those kinds of things are tells that
uh you're not
human yeah okay i had one thing oh real
quick
about that for the boot camp grad so
i think both of your answers were
fantastic and i always tell people like
it's never too early to start practicing
for a technical interview like
yeah months in advance like even if
you're not even thinking about getting a
tech job yet um pandemic or not like
start practicing for those
technical interview questions for sure
super important that can like literally
make or break
your opportunity of getting a tech job
and competing with other people who do
have computer science degrees
however if you're a coding bootcamp
graduate or soon to be or someone else
looking to get a job in tech
and you're feeling a lot of pressure
because it's like wow i'm going into
the job market in like the worst
possible time like literally when was
the last time you had a major pandemic
like this
affecting our lives like i don't know
like
like what this in 1918 or something so
years ago
yeah so yeah so like give yourself some
grace
like like realize that these are crazy
unforeseen circumstances and if you're
in a situation where you need a job to
support yourself or your family
it is completely okay to have a
temporary job plan
even if you did just go to this coding
bootcamp even if you did just graduate
from a degree with or a school computer
science degree
uh of course go after those positions
but do something else in the meantime to
make ends meet
and there are companies like i know
instacart is doubling their customer
support
um staff by the end of may so i think
they have 1200 now and they're going to
be
going up to 3 000 like but yeah by the
end of may so like six weeks or
something
maybe a customer support role at
instacart isn't your dream job
but nonetheless i think it could even be
a step in the right direction depending
on what industry you're coming into
because
instacart is still a tech company maybe
you
you know again maybe it's not exactly
what you want but it could be a step
there you could get your foot in the
door at that company
or maybe you could leverage that
experience in the future
to get a job at another delivery company
of sorts but
as a junior developer so give yourself
some grace this is a really hard time
right now
and like just take that in as you you
know go about your job search
i would like to bring to this something
to the focus here
like what advice do you have for
developers who are planning to
uh land a job uh in companies like
facebook and google because today
morning
uh cheryl from facebook announced that
they are gonna hire
10 000 people in engineering and product
by the end of the year
so what advice do you have for
developers to
apply for these companies and also crack
those jobs
for oh i i actually i'm not sure if i
would be the best to answer this because
a lot of my experience is like at
startups and whatnot but i did see this
statistic you're talking about as far as
um facebook playing to hire 10 000 more
developers
which is like literally five times the
size of my college that's like a town
of how many developers that they're
hiring i know they have a lot of
employees though
but i feel like eileen maybe you'd be
better at answering that and like
approaching
um a big tech company like that yeah i
mean my
uh my advice is not going to be that
different for those companies than than
for other groups again
um right now those companies are getting
hit really really hard because everybody
views them as a stable place to work
right so uh they are some of the only
ones that are advertising loudly that
they're hiring during this time
they also pay more so even even in an
easy easy economy it's hard to get
noticed and here it's going to be
even harder so um if you can
try to get a referral in try to um
chances are a lot of them one thing that
people don't know about recruiters
at these companies is that most
recruiters are contractors and i'll
explain why i'm talking about this in a
moment
so um what can happen sometimes is you
get reached out to by a recruiter if
you're fortunate enough for that to
happen
and then by the time you see it maybe
you missed it you reach back out to them
and they're no longer there
these people are usually contractors
that work at these companies for six
months stints and then they move on to
the next place
so again i would try to forge a genuine
authentic
relationship with an engineer at one of
these companies maybe an engineering
manager
maybe think about which teams
might be hiring more than others you'll
still have to go through that like
centralized interview process
but at least you'll have somebody um put
your hat
into the ring um so that's that's one i
know that's not super useful advice the
fact is like it's really
really hard and it's gonna get even
harder but if you are fortunate enough
to get in
and this is um extra important
interviews at these companies are very
very difficult
and they tend to follow a very very
specific pattern
and you really only get one shot one one
piece of data that we've seen on our
platform
over and over is that the same engineer
can do
very very well in a technical interview
one day and then the next day
absolutely bomb even if those interviews
are of comparable difficulty with
engineers who are comparably strict
it's because the interview process is
just fundamentally non-deterministic
and there's just so much room for error
the best thing you can do
once you get your foot in the door is to
spend even longer than i advise before
preparing for interviews so that when
you do get your opportunity
you don't screw it up here's another
thing that i've seen a lot of people do
wrong
sometimes somebody is so happy that they
finally hear from one of these big
companies
that the recruiter who's incent i mean
recruiters are incentivized to make
hires as quickly as possible because
they're compensated on it and
they're they're uh generally uh that's
like their um
their bar for performance that doesn't
mean that you have to interview
immediately if facebook reaches out to
you they get back to you and they say
okay great get on the phone with a
facebook engineer
next week if you're not ready just push
it out and they're gonna be okay with it
don't panic don't say okay this is my
only chance i'm just gonna cram the
night before
it's gonna if you've never done these
kinds of interviews it will take you
months
so accept that push your interview off
schedule it a few months
out and then spend hours a day preparing
so i might be able to touch a bit on the
like fang or large companies there
so um one of my friends he wanted to
uh work at google well i don't know if
he wanted to work at google but what he
did was uh he was reached out from
uh uh from recruiters uh within google
and he went all the way he went all the
way and they
offered them the job and then he said no
so he didn't really want the job
he loved the challenge and now he he
makes video games he lives on an island
uh and but the thing the thing about
that is that he's
uh they said okay well who should we uh
who should we hire since you're so great
who can you recommend and then they
reached out to me and so i was going
through the process and then i did the
same thing i went
yeah you know what i'm having fun doing
this but really i'm not going to see to
the end so i'm going to stop here
and they went to me and said who can you
recommend so
um you know if you if if you know any
friends who've gone through the process
um or or make friends with other people
that are going through it because maybe
they can pass you along
and and the process is very uh uh
uh random so like i was going really uh
really well through google
i cannot get hired at aws to save my
life and it makes no sense because
everybody around me
you'll be able to work that says you are
qualified um the process is crazy i've
had
like senior uh senior development
developer advocates reach out to me
and say to me you know i had to apply
five times
to work to work here before i got in so
you just have to take your bumps
and realize that it's going to be a very
difficult process
i can say that you know for any of these
companies assist well depends for the
job but
systems design is a very important thing
so understanding how to build a complex
systems
so or looking for a systems design
engineer if you
google those terms those might help you
understand conceptually how to put
things together and obviously there's
algorithmic challenges interview
preparation if you could find any good
services for that that would be great
too
um you know so that's just my two cents
on on that part
uh just one more thing to add there um
if you are from india and you're coming
to canada
last year we started fast tracking visas
to india because we really want more
talent here
um so so there's a lot of opportunities
uh there as well
if you want to work at a big company but
not necessarily one of the fan companies
there's good recruiters like uh van hack
i always hear really good things about
them
and you might think that right now
there's no opportunities because
there's no way to uh there's no way to
bring people actually into canada
um but what what's happening is that
these companies are hiring the remote
and they're waiting for everything to
blow over
and then they bring them into canada so
we're not seeing a drop
drop in there uh if uh if you want to
get into cloud jefferson frank is a
really really good recruiter
if you want to get into data science
roles or anything data in canada we
career is really really good they're not
a recruiter but
they they know a lot of companies uh
that can get you placed
um and those are the three recorders
that i like generally i don't have a
good relationship with recruiters
um so i do like to mention the ones that
i feel that uh do care about you and are
trying to do a good job and they're the
ones that are
working on contract and they're trying
to push every person every
applicant uh into that into that uh that
box you know
laurence uh do you have any friends who
are
applying for like large you know that we
say fang but that could also include you
know shopify could
include infosys and microsoft and a lot
of other big companies
that are actively applying not
that i know of um i feel like a lot of
the people that
i'm around either well actually honestly
don't work in tech because
i grew up i was not in tech at all right
so a lot of my friends from
college and before that are not in tech
uh or like
startups like my husband um just like we
met
actually at the last art that we worked
at and now he just started his new
startup
i do this um so a lot of like the people
that were kind of
around a lot of the time are more so in
the startup world but i have been
reached out by
or i have been reached out to from
recruiters from
google definitely and um one of the
things that you were saying andrew in
your example
i know that at least one of the people
it was because someone else i know that
he was working at youtube he gave her my
information because i also do think
please correct me if i'm wrong um but
say if i did end up working there he
would get a referral he would be like a
bonus right
yes so like they really incentivized
employees
for good people yeah yeah i i'm not sure
if it's the same with candidates as well
but yes
yeah i don't yeah i'm not sure about
that but yeah for the people who work
there it's like
good so they a lot of times will like
share
qualified people that they know of to
the recruiters that work
at those companies so yeah but
yeah well so there's a pretty big
gulf because a lot of people are in kind
of startup land and other people are in
like big company land like their they've
kind of got their sites set on
working for a big known company
um uh elene what would be your advice to
somebody
because we already heard a little bit
from andrew about applying to smaller
startups
uh but what how would you vary your
approach if you were going to go on the
job market today as a developer and you
wanted to work at
like a small upcoming company like for
example code sandbox
uh sid from code sandbox was on the
previous one and they're they're growing
they're still very small it's like i
think you said like nine people maybe a
company that has
closer to like 50 people like how would
your approach be different
there than applying to a microsoft or an
amazon
yeah depending on the company size let's
say it's under 20
i would probably reach out directly to a
founder
and ideally the cto right
that person is the one that has the most
leeway to make
exceptions companies of that size are
typically biased against hiring junior
talent because
uh when you're that small you don't
always have the luxury of thinking
months years ahead you're often kind of
thinking uh just a couple months ahead
and that means that you may not have the
bandwidth to train somebody up
and depending on the constitution of
your team you may not have the
mentorship
ability to get somebody from a to b
right
but rules are meant to be broken um
people that are not the founder will
probably be more risk-averse about
breaking those rules because everybody
has some amount of social capital at a
company
or and you use it you like you get a few
shots right and you you try to spend it
on things that are going to have the
best outcome
but if you're a founder you can do all
sorts of crazy [ __ ] right so
um i would i would probably reach out to
a founder
and um you know write the best most
concise
most authentic email that i can if i can
get an introduction to them even better
understand that founders are very very
busy they're probably
not spending more than a few seconds on
any email
so just say in the first two sentences
who uh what you want
and then explain why you deserve it and
that's the whole email
right maybe link to some things if
you've done cool stuff
uh for a slightly bigger company um who
probably is hiring juniors because they
do have that
mentorship bandwidth and the ability to
think ahead more
um you may want to reach out to say a
director of engineering
sometimes you get lucky and you find
stuff they've written
about hiring and if you can find
something they've written about hiring
and reference that and of course tell a
compelling story about how
hiring you fits into their world view
and thesis
that's a win they will definitely they
might not hire you but they will at
least answer you and once you
have your foot in the door then it's
just on you to show that you're capable
um but you know uh in in this climate if
you have a limited amount
of time and i would probably not spend
it on applying to very small companies
because they're dropping like flies
all right well that was some really good
advice
just just to recap what she said there a
lot of people
are proud of their hiring process and
they will publicly write about it like i
don't know if i've actually written
about how free co camp
hires but like if you want to work at
free code camp you just have to be
a prolific volunteer contributor and 100
of our hires come from people who are
already essentially working
as volunteers in the develop the
developer community
so if you can find like how they hire
that can be
huge information because you can just
kind of
go right into that flip stream and
present yourself as an ideal model so
knowing a lot about the
interviewing party and their uh their
thinking on things and how they think
about
yes and we have been getting a lot of
requests from twitter
uh andrea would you mind re-sharing the
recruiter's lists
so i absolutely will yeah you should
open source on github make a list or
something
and then share it with everybody oh yeah
if people tell me to do it i'll do it
yeah and
and laurence if you want to write
something we would
happily propagate these kinds of things
because this is precisely what people
are looking for is just
some some information that they can go
on uh
but the one of the big takeaways i'm
getting especially from
hearing aileen uh talk is
we should be practicing as much as
possible
and and this might be a really great
time to just really
go deep on learning algorithms data
structures design patterns and just
getting really good at programming so
that you can really
nail those interviews you can apply to
hundreds of jobs and you may have to
apply to hundreds of jobs anyway
to actually get uh interviews and and
get offers
but that process will be much easier if
when you actually do get those
interviews and when you
you know you're prepared
yeah so in terms of just
very quick advice for like what people
should prioritize
and you know let's say that they have
been handed this block of time
that they you know had previously eight
hours of sleep eight hours of work eight
hours of leisure very few people
actually had that split it's probably
closer to like
four hours of leisure maybe seven hours
of sleep but
if people do suddenly have a few extra
hours a day
what would be the most efficient
allocation of that time and we're just
going to go once around and that'll be
our closing question
uh we'll start with you alien great so
um if i it's going to depend on your
seniority level so for this i'll assume
that you're junior
and you haven't done a lot of this
before there's one great book whose name
escapes me but that i will get after
this and tweet it out
the theme of the book is basically
algorithms and data structures
for non-technical people that just learn
to code
so it breaks it down in this very
approachable way
and isn't super mathy is just mathy
enough
um i think it's exceptional so i will
get that uh that step one
is to just get your head around what
you're dealing with step two
is to work problems on your own there's
leet code and then there's a great uh
repository of problems that actually
shows you exactly the steps that you
would take to solve them called
interview cake
big fan of both of those step three once
you've read about read a little bit
about this and then actually
work some problems is to start
practicing
um we are not the only practice site out
there i think we do a great job
but even if you don't use us if you go
to interviewing dot io
recordings or just go to our main site
and then in the nav bar there's a link
called watch interviews
you can actually watch other people
practicing it's kind of like a
boring twitch if you will but
if you haven't seen these interviews
before you're just going to see what
interviews are like with google
engineers and microsoft engineers
and linkedin engineers and airbnb and a
bunch of other companies
so just watch those and then once you
get over the shock
then start practicing because working
problems on lead code
is very very different than working a
problem while somebody is breathing down
your neck and watching your every move
it's really really nerve-wracking
but the good news is once you get used
to it and once you get used to thinking
out loud
it gets better and then of course um
potentially one of your practice
interviewers
who's probably from fang can refer you
into that company
so there's there's a journey if i were
to do it awesome thank you alien
uh and uh laurence if you were if you
were going to go apply
for a job and you had some time how
would you how would you
spend that time preparing for a job
application spree
yeah i think i mean everything that she
said about interviewing was
great information i think beyond that
though just trying to build
a community and build i don't like to
use the word connections because it
feels so
like oh yeah i'm like going networking
events which we can't even do right now
can't go to meetups or networking events
but just building
friends essentially that work in the
tech space so obviously free code camp
is a great resource for that there's
also a number of different
slack communities for developers or for
other folks that work in technology or
design um
there are online events like this and i
know because i keep seeing a bunch in
the news there's other kinds of online
conferences and i imagine they have like
maybe like virtual breakout groups of
sorts where you can meet other people
and i think that is just like a great
way to spend your time right now and
as you were i'm chatting before about
getting jobs at startups i just
remembered i had a flashback to someone
i worked with at my last company who
studied philosophy in college
he was the company's first customer
support hire
he wasn't great at that role but he
taught himself how to code on weekends
and nights and he ended up building the
first
internal staff app no one asked him to
do it he just did it
on nights and weekends super helpful for
the company
he then became an engineer and now to
this day it's like
six years later he's leading the entire
internal tools pod and has people
reporting to him and this was someone
who
learned to code on nights and weekends
has a philosophy degree
and he just kind of showed up put
himself out there did things on his own
took you know initiative
and of course made connections with
people at the company or made
friendships and he's still there to this
day so
i think just making yourself useful and
building um or building friendships
okay awesome and andrew oh cool yeah so
i would say uh you want to build and
ship and document okay so build
applications
ship them off to small small startups
document your your journey so
so people can uh can find how you're
doing stuff
i believe there's a lot of startups
small startups that are are hiring
you you can uh create yourself your own
role
that is irreplaceable uh and i think
there's a lot of there's companies that
are
going away but there's a lot of
companies that are are thriving in this
industry
so look for those particular techs and
try to focus your energies uh there
and i think if you do those three things
i think that's gonna be a lot more
valuable
than anything else because if you can
produce
a value or result for a company in the
form of an application
that is your proof right um so that's
that would be my approach
awesome well i want to thank all three
of you
everybody watching scroll down follow
these people on twitter they're super
interesting
check out interviewing.io check out exam
pro and of course
all the awesome free courses that andrew
has already published on freecodecamp
for aws certification check out the
learn to code with me podcast
and laurence's blog
there are a ton of resources out there
everything you need to prepare for the
developer
interview process is out there just
explore those resources
i hope you all learned a whole lot from
these three people who've
been there and who've done that and are
kind of
sending information back through time to
you at your earlier stage
in your careers um thank you all
and we'll be right back with our final
panel of the day which is
around finding freelance opportunities
so don't go anywhere
uh enjoy some slides and some some music
for the next
10-ish minutes and we'll see you in a
sec thanks
thank you everybody thank you hey
everyone welcome back
this is the final segment of
lockdown conf we might do another one
depending on uh feedback i am going to
get a survey out
uh shortly after the event with the
hashtag lockdownconf
uh so if you all have feedback on ideas
you'd like us to discuss
for future events let us know but i am
thrilled
to introduce you all to three prolific
uh freelance workers very experienced in
this field
they're also people who have contributed
a great deal of uh
lessons and and courses to frico camp
over the years uh first bolaji uh
from nigeria he is a
seasoned freelancer and most recently
he's working at hashnode
as a developer and uh he knows quite a
bit we're going to hear a lot from him
hello how how's everything going with
you bolaji
hi quincy how's it going great to have
you here
uh next we have phoebe
fidel um she is a developer in the uk
and she has also worked extensively
as a freelancer and now is working
full-time at a company as a developer
um welcome phoebe thank you quincy
good to have you here and we have
luke siciliano who literally
wrote the course and the book on uh
freelancing
and he has uh done an incredible amount
of freelancing over the years
he i believe has done
25 years worth of freelancing and
running
a consultancy that does freelance
development work
and seo consulting and things like that
so we're
privileged to have with with us this
walking talking repository of
freelancing wisdom
so thank you very much for joining us
luke oh well thanks for having me it's
honestly it's my pleasure to be here so
yeah
well uh we are going to be talking
extensively
about freelancing this is a time when
many people are looking for work uh many
people
have unfortunately lost their jobs just
in the united states alone
uh unemployment claims which is just
people who can actually successfully get
through the phone to claim
unemployment benefits uh 16
million people over the past three weeks
so this has been absolutely devastating
uh to people here in the us and i
imagine
also in in nigeria and in the uk
and europe uh and
we are going to um we're going to
delve into all that but i just want to
preface this with
everybody who has who's listening here
who has been laid off or has been
furloughed
we're very sad about that situation
we're going to do
everything we can in our power to give
you the tools that you can go out
and you can find other organizations in
need
small businesses large businesses uh
nonprofits other organizations and that
you can
help them solve their own problems
through technology
as a as a freelancer so um my first
question
to all three of you uh and and we can
start with phoebe
um what
is freelance software development and
how would you describe
the field of freelancing as far as
you know doing software development
um so from my experience i i
freelance for experience because um i'm
a
career changer so i went from one
industry into another and
a lot of what i was doing i was learning
at home
and i wasn't having that kind of sort of
more
practical experience so i started
freelancing and
the easiest thing for me to do was to do
wordpress sites because
it's you know it's very low cost
for the client and so from that point of
view
i kind of approached um sort of local
businesses
um family and asked them if they wanted
websites
so i started quite low-key um purely for
experience
um and it kind of like snowballed from
there really
because i just did one site and then
word got around and then it kind of
you know kind of had a life of its own
so um
yeah so i think for me it was started
off just to get some experience but then
it kind of became a bit of a side
business
next to my studying and also i was
looking after my two kids at home
because i was the stay-at-home mom as
well so for me you know
you know i i wasn't aiming for something
that i was going to do for long term but
it kind of ended up that way
yeah and if if anybody is interested in
phoebe's story it's really
remarkable and uh she's written about it
at length
uh if you just google from stay at home
mom to
freelance developer i think is the
headline you'll pull it up
maybe somebody can share it in the chat
for everybody
but so phoebe used freelance development
as a way to transition into tech and i
think that's
pretty common bolaji how about you
how would you describe freelance
development and and your experience
freelancing in the past
okay um so basically i've been
freelancing for like two years now
and at the point where i started i was
just possibly a beginner
and like you know before you get hired
you have to get a point where you're
really experienced at least
um surpass the interviews and all that
right so at that point i wasn't really
so good but i knew what i was doing and
so that's one of the best way i could
practice my skills you know try it out
with friends families and know
hey i can do this i can do that and all
that so and then people were really
interested in
um having me um build stuff for them and
then
through that i was able to get um
started with building projects and all
that and
i was able to build stuff like a lot of
stuff and then i had um
so many clients around me and then while
growing i was learning more and then i
eventually um got hired and started
working professionally
but still i still feel as even up to now
like a freelance like
virtually every month because like i
started with freelance and like it's
really cool awesome
and uh luke tell us a little bit about
your experience in
25 years ago how you got into
freelancing um
i would say more than anything it really
just started by coming across a few
people with some problems that
i knew how to solve the specific answer
to your question
is i got asked to write an app
for a local deli that wanted to have a
street fighter 2 tournament back when
playing games in the arcade was like
actually a thing so i wrote an app so he
could track that and then
one thing led to another i would really
just define freelancing more than
anything else as as an individual
solving
other people's problems i mean and as
long as you just keep doing that people
are going to keep calling you
[Music]
okay awesome and uh
let's start with talking about what kind
of how the market may have
changed for freelance developers because
prior to freelance developers you know
we weren't in a global recession like we
are now
a lot of people had a lot more cash on
hand now
things may have tightened a little bit
the kind of people who are looking for
freelance
help may not be looking anymore others
may have new problems
that they're looking for freelancers to
solve
perhaps you could talk a little bit
about the kinds of new clients you're
getting
luke and and how they're approaching you
um right now i would say it's the
market's definitely changed and number
one like you were saying earlier i mean
we're all really fortunate to be in a
spot where we can keep working right now
as opposed to
being furloughed and so i'm just kind of
trying to make the most of that
opportunity
in terms of clients right now the first
thing i noticed
is quite a bit coming in from current or
previous customers just to give an
example
i built a progressive web app for a
small church about a year ago and
because of what's going on they couldn't
hold services so they wanted to
integrate
video streaming into their website so
getting a
surprising number of calls from either
customers i've been helping on an
ongoing basis or previous customers just
needing
something else done in some regard
in terms of other business beyond that i
think that this has
really created possibilities
while i know a lot of people may look at
a time of crisis like this and think
that
possibilities may be decreasing it's
true that a lot of possibilities
decrease but
other ones open up because
anytime anything creates a problem for
small businesses that's a
problem that needs to be solved and nine
times out of ten
or a lot of i shouldn't say nine times
that time a lot of times developers can
solve those kinds of problems so it's
definitely creating opportunities
anything ranging from
for example um the small local
restaurant that knows they've
needed a new website and app for the
last 10 years and they've just
never gotten around to it now all of a
sudden they're prioritizing that so
you know people can order online um
you know the consulting firm that's used
to dealing with people one-on-one now
they've got to deal with everyone
virtually so they need a mechanism where
people can securely submit documents to
them um
things like that this has really changed
the business needs of a lot of different
types of companies out there know that
those are problems that
developers can solve so those are the
new kinds of customers i'm largely
seeing as people
that now have a problem that they didn't
have before and they need that
problem solved and like i said that's
after just
doing things for previous customers
yeah and that makes perfect sense so
your previous customers are proactively
reaching out to you because you're on
their radar
right and and they know that you have
proven that you're capable
of solving the problems in the past so
they're reaching back out to you
um phoebe if you were to
uh like not magically not be working
your current job hopefully that doesn't
happen
but let's say hypothetically you were to
go back on the market as a freelancer
like
how would you re-establish contact with
past customers and let
let them know like hey i'm i'm back in
business and
whom would you approach and like what
would be your general strategy for that
um well actually i maintain contact with
all my clients a lot of them i have like
a
care package with them so i maintain
their domain
and their hosting and i get in touch
with them
you know once every couple of months and
sort of say is everything okay
just checking in so i kind of maintain
that relationship with them anyway
um but in terms of sort of finding
new clients i think it's just um
usually actually i get approached i get
approached now um
even when i'm working full-time um
and with the pandemic actually i think
people have had that kind of downtime
when they start thinking about
um i should really get back into looking
into that website i need to update so
i've had um actually a few contacts that
i've got in touch with me saying
can you work on the website so
unfortunately i've had to turn people
away but i've referred it to
other people i know in the field um
so it's kind of it's kind of a strange
situation because i noticed that the
work stopped and then the moment that
this
horrible situation happened people
started getting back in touch
so i guess like you know i would
probably approach local businesses
see if they're okay and sort of say do
you need any kind of updating
um and that's what i did when i was
freelancing anyway i would sort of make
contact
and usually through my existing networks
so it doesn't come across as cold
calling i guess
so you know say hey i know this person
you know heard that you
might possibly need a website updating
and i think that works best
kind of building that trust um and you
know
having that kind of credibility already
so it's you know if you get referred on
by someone else that really helps
so awesome and it's great to hear
both of you have existing relationships
that are continuing with these people
and
a lot of things that if you're new to
freelancing you may think oh i built
that and it's done
but it sounds like a lot of your work uh
as a freelancer is maintenance of code
and making sure that things continue to
work would you
would you say that's accurate phoebe
yeah i agree yeah
definitely and it's just you know a lot
of time you know
um some of my clients don't have a
massive budget
so they say oh i want this and i said
but they can't afford to do it and i
said well that's fine you know we can
build
features on top you know once you get
the budget
um so it's it's you know so it's kind of
prioritizing what they want and what
they need and trying to differentiate
the you know rather desire versus what
they actually need
to get the website off you know so um
yeah so i say definitely
maintenance and just adding new features
as well um
it's just kind of a continued
relationship
awesome and uh fazel uh within the
hashnow community what pro what
proportion of people would you say that
are really active on hash node
are interested in freelancing or doing
freelance development
um i would say uh we don't get a lot of
questions or discussions specifically
for related to freelancing
so uh i'm not sure that we can
i can come up with a number on number of
people who are actively looking for
freelancers on hash project
because uh we don't get questions on
those
uh on on this area
okay well well do you uh have you
noticed any discussions
around this uh yeah with linking yes
yes uh one question that i have um like
uh often come across
is people like there are developers who
are uh
trying to get into freelancing for the
first time there's maybe
this may be new new uh developers
beginner developers or experienced
developers
so what advice do you have for people
like this
how can they start their freelancing
career
okay awesome uh and uh have any of you
found like aside from uh luke's
comprehensive course by the way uh it's
right here on this youtube channel you
can check it out
after this if you're interested in
freelancing uh it's
several hours long and it he also has
like a lawyer
like a small business lawyer and like an
accountant uh so
it's kind of full spectrum small
business advice for people who want to
become freelance developers and i
strongly encourage everybody to check
that out
aside from that what are some other
resources
you all have found over the years that
you've found
helped you a lot communities
or other learning resources that are
useful for
premises that they should be aware of
i would i honestly think the things i
found most useful
are not necessarily even uh related to
uh working as a coder or freelancing in
general but just uh
general business books uh general
personal finance books
things of that nature um i strongly
strongly
and a whole bunch of strongly's uh think
that
you know working for yourself as a
developer or working for yourself as an
independent baker or working for
yourself running you know as an
independent auto mechanic really
aren't all that different i think you
know a lot of it
just kind of comes down to the same
ideas and some
same basic principles so i think anyone
who is
trying to strike out on their own right
now in addition to
just reading as much as they can about
uh you know
i guess what i'm trying to say is don't
limit your reading to how do i start up
my independent dev shop or how do i
start
making money as a freelancer start
reading as much as reading and absorbing
as much as you can about being
self-employed in general
i would say that that's the probably the
best resource that a lot of people could
engage in a couple of books i would
probably suggest
just off the top of my head um one is
called
the millionaire next door um i actually
think that should be required reading in
high schools that's just
you know my personal opinion which you
know it doesn't count for much obviously
that one a book called the innovators by
walter isaacson is you know like a
really really good one and a book called
profit first
which is really just about managing the
finances of a small business
profit first might even be the first one
i would say somebody should read right
now
yeah and i haven't read the millionaire
next door but my understanding is it's
an older book
and it it really uh the book's
core thesis i think is that anybody
who's working like a middle class type
job and this may not be completely true
in 2020 where we've got you know a lot
of people working as contractors
and having limited access to opportunity
but people who are making
like the median level wage for an
american which would
in america it's about i think it's like
sixty thousand dollars is now the median
wage it's gone up a little bit
um if you can figure out ways to cut
costs and save a whole lot of money
you can use that as a as a nice cushion
and you can invest
in the stock market maybe not the stock
market but you'll
you'll get enough recurring
revenue from that that it just keeps
reinvesting and i think it's like the
benjamin
franklin quote about like the most
powerful force in the universe's
compound interest
right uh yeah actually that may have
been an einstein quote
because it doesn't sound as profound
coming from somebody who's focused on
money but
from somebody who's focused on science i
think that compound interest is so
powerful
uh so so just to
to process a little bit about what luke
said there
general business books can be just as
helpful as anything else because a lot
of what you're trying to do
is figure out the physics of business uh
so that you can keep your organization
alive and that ultimately you can
provide your
for your family and uh you know keep the
the cash coming in which is the
lifeblood of any business
um so so thank thanks for sharing this
uh yeah so one question that we have
uh is how can uh freelancers market
themselves
developers developer freelancers can
market themselves during these times
right if they are starting out what uh
do you have any tips for them
and it'd be great to get uh your
perspective on this belagi
if you have advice since um i know uh
nigeria is very competitive market there
are a lot of really skilled developers
there
yeah yeah right
so when it comes to marketing it starts
from your network itself
um it's much more like internal than
external so marketing starts from your
small
peers like your friends your families
your neighbors and all that so like you
start marketing from people around you
um like your closest sphere should
understand that this is what i do
and then they are the ones who like go
out and market your external and say oh
i have a friend that does
this so you possibly might not be able
to reach out to someone
um let's secrecy i might not be able to
reach out to questions friends
but quincy knows me right and he knows i
i do the stuff and i do it well enough
so
quincy can go out and talk to his
friends about me and say oh i
do this stuff and then that's it they
reach out to queen c and queen c
connects me today i'm like i've done
like
huge marketing right there like without
having to um
do a lot of marketing strategies and all
that like i just work with my peers and
work with my friends
right and another good option you might
want to try out
is social media like that's a really
good place to like market yourself
one thing you should note about
marketing is people would um
love you if they can see what you're
doing right so like i'm not just
marketing and saying hey
i can view this stuff and then that's it
no i told you i can do this stuff and
this is the stuff i've built right
and then i look at and i'm like wow this
is awesome i like it like
how can i reach out to you can you do
the same stuff for me right so
i am marketing with like proof i'm
showing them samples of stuff i've done
and then
through that i can get more um clients
and more returns from that
so it's it's very simple start marketing
from your peers like your small friends
and families
and then as much as you're trying to
market on social media or the platform
try as much as possible to show samples
show them stuff you build like
live projects and all that and through
that you would be able to like
get a lot of clients that would be
interested in you and even if they would
not be interested at that moment it's
like it's
more like stored in their catalog and
they're like ah there's this guy i saw
like one month ago oh
i'm used to this awesome stuff right and
i want to reach out to him so like
just by doing that alone you're
preparing like more clients for yourself
so that's it basically
awesome and uh one question that we have
from chat is uh how do you figure out
how much to charge
as a freelance developer and
uh how do you triangulate prices that
clients will actually pay
you that's a hard one
yeah i mean like i think for me um
because i was new to the scene and
i hadn't had much experience um i kind
of
just did it as i'm starting from the
bottom i'm just going to
charge my time because i'm getting
experience but people are taking a
chance from me
and i kind of took it from there really
and also with demand so
the more demand that came in i kind of
adjusted my prices accordingly because
you know
um so i kind of like responsed the
market
almost but at the start i did kind of
offer a
i built um my first site for free
because i wanted the experience i kind
of want to do a real kind of client
relationship but not have kind of
pressure on myself
and then um and then from there i kind
of
did um what i would call the equivalent
of the minimum wage
um and then once i kind of built up my
confidence and i thought ah okay and now
i can start charging
kind of more the rates that i i think
equate with my skills
so it's just kind of building up from
there really and you know it's
it's a hard one i mean like it also
depends on
your clients budget and you kind of
don't want to
undersell yourself but you also have to
sort of if they say we've only got x
amount of pounds
to do this site you can say i can build
this this and this for you
and you kind of prioritize what can be
built so
i would say it just depends on your
experience and
and and just take it from there really
the more you build
the bigger your reputation becomes you
get more kind of clout
and then you can probably start charging
a bit more so i kind of adjusted as i
went along
and that makes that makes sense and
that's a really reasonable way
to approach it um and how about you look
like how have you negotiated
uh price elasticity among your uh
your clients um fortunately right now
i'm
kind of in a phase where my price is my
price and
i don't don't negotiate it down too much
to be frank
um now if i wasn't in that situation
um i think what phoebe said uh just said
hits the nail on the head more than
anything
when she said uh when the client says
here's my budget
and you say i can do a b and c
um to do is i just think that's an
import just such an important part of
selling something and coming up with the
right price if you know if
if a customer says you know i want
items one two and three and and
the developer just says here's what it's
going to cost and they say that's not
what's in my budget
that that's kind of the developer saying
too bad and then
you know the person's obviously not
going to buy the services and
it's not good for anybody another way to
think of that is
don't end by telling somebody no right
if somebody says
i need one two and three and this is my
budget
and you just say no then that's just the
end of the conversation whereas
what if you say here's what i can do for
you so it's kind of like
well um you know i can't build you your
own uh
you know i can't you know i can't build
your own uh
video player but i'm happy to embed
youtube for you so you can stream it
live so in other words end with what you
can do for them as opposed to what you
can't do for them
and then they suddenly feel like they're
getting a deal within their limited
budget and it
helps make the sale helps keeps the
price down it just works out better for
everybody
and a lot of times uh clients may not
know what they want
and they may but they do know what the
problem is so they're the stakeholder
they can describe what the problem is
and as a freelancer you can interpret
that problem into a potential solution
and right size it and you know make it
like like you just said the cost of
creating your own video streaming stool
and uh
having your own video player and all
that stuff may be prohibitive
but the cost of embedding youtube may
only be
you know a day's work uh to be able to
have them have a tool where they can
update the video and everything right so
yeah yeah
i think what you just said is actually
really really important um i've finished
uh two sports related apps
for different clients i would so doesn't
matter let's call it within
the last 30 days and um
you know and everybody else on the panel
will can talk we'll say this too that
you know when we get clients that call
us
a client will say you know i want
whatever it is they want and it's really
important to give those clients feedback
you can give them possibilities that
they didn't know they had in front of
them they obvious they'll instantly see
how those possibilities can
you know help their business and it's
also important to give them feedback if
they're saying they want certain
features or functionality that
you know from having done something
similar is probably a bad idea
it's important to in polite terms
explain to them why it's a bad idea why
they shouldn't you know spend the money
on that
and um so on and so forth and that also
just really goes a long way towards
a getting people to sign up for with you
be you know helping them you know get
the most for
you know like their money and and things
of that um
you know it's really important as a
freelancer to think yourself as a
problem solver and it's hard to solve a
problem without giving feedback to
somebody
right um so i just i just think you
really just hit the nail on the head
that's really important to not just
take a call and say someone says to you
i want one two and three and you just
say okay it's really important to give
them that feedback
um i just want to add to what luke said
um
yeah i mean i completely agree about
giving the client feedback because a lot
of the time
they don't know what they want or they
don't know how the best way to solve the
problem
so um and i find that you know some
people probably think oh i shouldn't
really say that i
think i'm being critical but in fact
they appreciate the advice because
you're
you know you you have more experience
that you know what you're talking about
so
um they're like i never thought of it
that way so
actually giving back feedback is is
probably a good thing and you should be
honest as well i think that's
that's another thing don't just keep on
saying yes yes i think that's a great
idea
i think being honest and they actually
do appreciate that so
yeah i just wanted to add that to luke's
comments
awesome uh i have an interesting
question for luke
uh look if you had to start freelancing
today
what are the three things you would not
do
what are the three things i would not do
if i had to start
that list is probably a lot longer than
three things first of all
um and it would also include a lot of
the mistakes i made early on
um if i had to start over today
um i would say some of the things
um that i would definitely stay away
from and
this is going to sound counterintuitive
to a lot of people
i wouldn't focus on trying to get as
many sales as possible on day one i
would really focus on trying to get that
first sale
and doing as good a job for that client
as i could um in other words get that
first product in and
probably just focus on that until it's
out the door because then not only
have you been paid for a completed
product you've got someone who's a
potential referral source now because
you've just done
a really good job for them um so
one thing i think a lot of people a big
mistake a lot of people make early on
myself
included is how do i get my name out
there to
as many people as possible on day one
it's like no no get your name out there
to
one person who will hire you today you
know that's
that's probably the first thing i would
do the
second thing i would definitely avoid
and this is going to sound
counterintuitive
to a lot of people is i would avoid
going to
a lot of networking events which is
another mistake i made
early on um you know
once when you go to a networking event
there are so many hours in a day and
that time is gone forever
and for the most part it's all they're
all a little different but for the most
part you're hoping to meet people that
will connect you with
other people at networking events i
think if you're going to go out and try
to sell yourself to people like that
it's you can just as easily spend that
time walking into the local bakery and
saying hey you know i notice you don't
have online ordering i notice you don't
have this let me
solve these problems so go out and try
to meet your customers one on one as
opposed to
trying to meet them through other people
that was another mistake you know i made
um early on
and i would say the third mistake
um that i probably made early on that i
would
uh definitely not repeat is and this may
sound
like i'm on my soapbox but you know
definitely
learning as much as i can about the
business issues from day one
getting set up for proper tax structures
and
things of that nature um because
kind of what quincy was saying about
compound interest earlier is really true
and if you start off with some bad
structures in place
and by structures i mean how you've
structured your business for taxes
um how you've set up some of your
workflows and those kinds of things if
you start off in a bad spot
those things are just going to compound
as you start getting more customers
and more and more money bleeds out of
your business as a result of it
so you know in not necessarily in those
orders
in that order those are the three things
i would really
not do is you know and again i think
what i did early on is what a lot of
people do i thought
oh boy i'm in business and i just went
plowing out without thinking about
how do i structure things for taxes and
you know like like things of that nature
and at the end of the year i regretted
it you know like way back when
so wow that's a great list
how about you phoebe um
i would say yeah i mean it's it's
it's different from because i used to
work for a company they took care of
you know paying me or the taxes and
there's
quite a steep learning curve when you go
self-employed
you know you have to you know you have
to do self-assessment
in the uk you have to be aware of you
know you have to have
insurance to make sure that you know
that you don't get sick if you get sued
you're covered
you know things like that that you don't
necessarily think about because
you you haven't had to think about it
yet so i think it's
like what luke said it's just kind of
having that infrastructure in place
you know using kind of an online
accounting tools
um so i started using wave which was
an invoicing tool rather than producing
them myself um
you know things like that just kind of
learn as you go on the job
um but it is quite hard i mean i think
you have to be prepared for that you you
know you don't have someone else taking
care of that you don't have like a
hr department you don't have a finance
department you know so it's it's all you
so if you are going to freelancing just
just kind of be aware of that
and um read up on it make sure you're
aware of
what's you know you need to do to to um
so that you don't get hit by the tax man
and
you get fined et cetera so um yeah i
mean i think for me i didn't realize how
much was involved
um and i wish i was better prepared for
it at the beginning but
you know once i did learn i i made sure
that i
caught up with it so awesome
and uh bolaji what are some things that
you made
mistakes you made early on that you've
uh
kind of learned from okay yeah um so the
first thing would be understanding that
i'm freelancing it's not just about
writing code like it's way much more
than just writing code like it's
it decompasses um communication
marketing and so much more
so like if you focus at the early stage
is just writing code you would miss out
from
so many goodies i've had times where i
had to write like
serious complex features for the clients
but meanwhile they really don't want all
that and then at the end i have to like
cut down most of these things and i'm
like what this is really good like
you need this you need and then like i
don't need it i know that's right
so um the ability to communicate well
with your clients it's very very
essential because like
luke said like most of them don't know
what they want and
most of when they have ideas of what he
wants but like not like the full idea
and then when they tell you i want x and
then tell them oh you can
you can get like an xyz or something
like oh this is cool
and most time you can tell them you can
get like an xyz and they tell you
um i don't really need that that's too
complex for me at the moment and then
you have to go back and forth i'm trying
to communicate with them it's like
first of all on the standard it's not
just about writing code like it's way
much more than that so if you're working
for a company you have tax and also you
just go just pick a ticket and just work
on your tax
for freelancing you're trying to build
something for someone who is not you
it's like you have to put yourself in
their position and try to understand
what
they want and this also leads to like my
second
regret that i would like which i never
did is try as much as possible to give
feedback to your clients like
um let's say weekly okay let's say the
deadline for the project is like one
month
try to give like demos in like maybe
four times in a month because like if
you wait to the end of the
one month you might present the entire
day when they're like wow why this why
it happened
you have to go back and revive so many
things like right so
you can do weekly demos with them and
then the first week you look at and i'll
tell you what um
i change this and change that and you
can easily revise because it's not going
so far
but like imagine you've gone like one
month into the project you have to go
back to like
three weeks ago like that's really
really stressful so the ability to give
feedbacks to your clients like
um weekly or like three days it's very
very important
and i think the last one for me would be
to automate stuff like i made
i always tell people like as much as we
are developers like we have so much to
do like there's
so much to do you have to install this
install that like the tooling we use is
quite much more than the code we
actually write so like
one thing we should try to do is um
automate stuff and that's one mistake i
never
did so like the time i spent trying to
do some basic stuff if i had automated
them i wouldn't have to spend that time
doing those things so like you can use
aliases and and so much more like try to
automate some of your swillings and
workflows
so it makes um it gives you much more
time to like do more works like
that's it
awesome that's an excellent answer all
three of you have a lot of wisdom
on this topic um i want to talk a little
bit about
the experience of trying to because a
lot of people ask
like oh i'm in india specifically trying
to find freelance
opportunities and i realized that's
probably very different from
the us in terms of like we have
completely different types of businesses
uh here in the us and lots of different
opportunities are there any
is let me just say is there any advice
that you think specific to
people in your country or your region uh
might be really helpful
for uh finding freelance customers uh
and because i i'll just say that
like a lot of people a lot of times i'll
give people freelancing advice i'll be
like oh
why don't you try talking to this and
this and they'll be like well it's a
little bit different
in india we don't have that like uh i i
realize this is a really really vague
question but i'm just curious if there's
some insight that i
as as an american uh am missing out on
that in the more global freelancing
field might be like super actionable
[Music]
i think um it's something
i mean i don't know if it's specific to
the uk but i found
um that kind of um
approaching people face to face i mean i
know we can't do that now but
during the pandemic but just kind of all
picking up the phone um
that really helped kind of having that
kind of one-to-one relationship
um and i noticed that when um you know
particular clients they kind of wanted
you more local so
they didn't want someone who was abroad
they wanted someone local that they can
sort of go to it's kind of like even
though you can work remote they kind of
wanted that safety net like
you know we want to be able to you know
call you or you can come to us and you
know you can talk it out so
it's kind of um i don't know if that's
specific to the uk but i found that with
clients they kind of
it does help kind of being in that local
area and
having the option to to kind of get in
touch with you when they can
on their time zone and um or in person
or on the phone that's just that kind of
availability thing
i don't know if it's if it's kind of a
specific uk thing
yeah and i find that too that of the new
customers i get who aren't
you know existing i mean i get them from
all over but i do get a surprising
number just from people that are
looking for somebody in their local
market
the one thing i'll say wherever
anybody is is yeah it
try to approach people from a
problem-solving standpoint i know i keep
saying this over and over and i
i don't mean to sound like a broken
record um
but like right now you know like here in
the united states and here in dayton
i think just about everywhere in the
united states
uh most restaurants for just as an
example most restaurants can only do
you know like carry out so instead of
you know if you're gonna call let's say
you're gonna cold call people instead of
cold calling you know just random
businesses
you know the restaurants have a problem
that needs solved you know they need
people to be able to order food online
and schedule a time to pick it up and
things like that so instead of saying
i'm gonna
instead of taking the approach of i'm
gonna look for work and i'm just gonna
call every business in my neighborhood
you know like let's say or something of
the sort
what i would say is identify a class of
customers and under the example i just
gave restaurants
and you know then say here's a class of
customers
what problem are they having
specifically right now
especially right now with everything
going on and when you call them
you know you're not going to have to
tell them they have a problem they know
they have a problem
and you know i think a lot of people
would be surprised at how often
they are pleased to be getting a call
from somebody
you know is reaching out with a
problem-solving standpoint you've got an
issue let me
fix it for you and so i think whatever
market you're in whether it's
a state somewhere in the u.s whether
it's a another country like india
whether it's a place like the uk or just
pick a place try to identify what kind
of problems people in that market are
having and
present yourself as someone who's
solving them and i really do think
that's the biggest answer to the
question
and one of the things that you touched
on there is because
we're all trapped in our homes uh due to
the pandemic and
and doing the responsible thing in
social distancing in virtually every
country i think
in some places like south korea they've
got the testing so
on lockdown that they are out able to
release the lockdown
that was really bad sorry um
but what i wanted to ask is
what are some strategies because you
know there's of course email there's
calling
but what are some some ways that
generally seem to work for
contacting people virtually when you
can't just walk into a bakery
and and say like hey i've been using
your bakery like buy something and then
like use that as like a reciprocation
technique or something like that by the
way
i can build this for you you know when
you can't actually talk to people face
to face and you have to rely on
email communication or other modalities
what are some tips
are there any specific platforms that
you found are really helpful for
finding clients anything like that i
mean honestly i
my first suggestion would be to just
call people on the phone
and and if you call and leave someone a
voicemail
or a message on their machine and you
know say you're calling a local business
and they don't call you back don't be
shy about calling
say over the course of a week or two
don't be shy about calling two or three
times now after a while if they don't
call you back then obviously you stop
calling them but
don't be shy about you know call you
know calling two or three times
um getting someone on the phone is just
a lot more personal than
you know an email or something of the
sort
um so a i would say get people on the
phone
but also as soon as you get people on
the phone
you know uh pres i would say present it
from their perspective
um you know like let's say uh
uh like i just built an app for a
laundromat
in my local area and uh
what's a dry cleaning establishment and
just because of the situation
he doesn't want people coming up to the
window you know he wants people
you know scheduling stuff and so when i
call him and
uh talked to him about i know you you
know you um
i know you're preferring to just do
scheduling like etc etc and i said
let's build something so people can just
schedule online with you
okay um so for example if you're calling
a restaurant you know
presented as i would like to help your
customers be able to order food from
your restaurant online
you know not i want to hire i want you
to hire me to do something though
presented as here's what i want to do to
help you improve your business here's
what i want to do to help your customers
and i think that's just uh in just my
personal opinion i think that's a way
better way to approach somebody
versus um hi i'm a web developer um i'd
like to talk about building something
for you
which says pay me some money whereas let
me help your customers says let me help
you make more money
yeah and i guess you can always pitch it
as like
look you're going to make a whole lot
more money the money that you're ending
up paying me will just be a drop in the
bucket compared to
the additional business you get uh so so
like the benefit to them is going to
completely offset any cost to them and
and ideally there won't be any risk
either
right so um how about you phoebe do you
have any tips for
uh how you in the past to have you
how did you find your clients and how
that would be different today
when we're all under lockdown um
yeah i mean it's a hard one because um i
did kind of rely more on the
face-to-face and i think i built a lot
of kind of clients through that
medium but um you know i guess you can
just transfer that to more
kind of video conferencing um i mean
like it's
strange with the younger generation i
find that they kind of prefer to be
messaged you know kind of like
whatsapp and things like that initially
um
so i i mean i would move it more to kind
of having
regular meetings but instead of face to
face having the video conferencing
using google meet or something like that
um
but yeah i mean like it's it's kind of
in a way it's
it's no different um you know you're
just using
a tool to talk to them but um i think
uh if you are going to approach clients
like what luke said i think
it's you have to approach it the right
way you you want to become across as the
problem solver
and i find that if you do your research
on the business
it really helps so then it looks like
you've put the effort in
so you know i always look at it to see
if they've got an existing website
how can i improve it and then you've
kind of you know and usually they kind
of appreciate that
so kind of not just cold calling said
hey i'm a web developer what do you need
built you kind of say i've looked into
your website i think you can improve
this you can improve
you know you look at the analytic you
know the um you can look at the speed of
the website if you can look at you know
the accessibility you can go into
uh the chrome dev tools and have a look
um through lighthouse and you can sort
of
you know you can do things like that and
then approach them so
um but yeah i think it's just kind of
getting your foot in the door
um you know getting them to respond to
you and
you can and i would say be persistent
email
you know phone calls you know and and
yeah and i say utilize your network as
well
awesome and balaji how have you found
your freelance clients in the past and
how would that be different now
uh in light of the pandemic okay
um so for me i i never really
went out to look for clients at the
early stages i
much more got more referrals than me
looking at clients and i never used
emails because like emails doesn't work
for me
i only use emails when i have to like
maybe um communicate like send files and
all that but like
i think to go more personal with my
clients like check them out and then we
have video calls more often than normal
and then we have phone calls because
that way i can
communicate more with them and
understand um their needs
right so i do that a lot i call them and
then we chat and then we get to
understand okay this is what you want
and
um this is what you need right and
that's worked very very effectively for
me
and like one other thing i would say is
trying to build up like your
um your portfolio like your your
appreciation because at the early stage
um no clients will come up to you if
they don't see something good enough
you've done yeah it's like
that's really strange like it's really
real for you to find out like
while you're starting out you need to
build more stuff because like you get
more clients when they see you done more
stuff because most
often clients would reach out to you
either from seeing um your work from
somewhere else and then they like reach
out and like i want the same thing right
so try as much as possible to like build
up your portfolio like allow your
clients to see one or two or three
projects you've done that are really
sexual
and that way you can easily um
communicate with them like it's not like
saying ah
i do this for this person this is these
are the results from um
what i did and then here's what i can do
for you also like i'm fully said like
um reaching out to them by telling them
you want to improve something from their
already existing products is an
effective way to like get them to use
you
i know i've reached out some clients and
i'm like oh i checked out your website
and then it's not really accessible and
they're like what's accessibility like i
now have an opportunity like to explain
to them what it really means and then
tell them why they're losing out and why
they're losing some clients and then i
tell them
your images are so large or like your
your website is not optimized and
they're like what's all that and then i
i break it down to them and let them
understand why they need to optimize
stuff and why their website needs to be
accessible right
so them understanding those concepts
they're not like oh wow like
i really didn't think about this right
so they now have to like um
go to the resources i sent today one is
okay okay um i'm really interested in
this and then how do we go about it
so like i've done two things now i
educated them on why they should solve
this problem and then
i can now come in and say oh now i'm
here to solve the problem for you
so it's much more than just um using a
product for them like it goes beyond
just trying to
understand the problem that comes from
the existing project like
luke said also when you understand um
what problem they have already based on
the existing project you can reach out
to them and explain how they can improve
it based on your own experience
oh no go ahead luke can i add just one
thing to all that
i mean sure i completely agree if every
in this more just of an ad
to what everybody just said but the one
thing i
and to get back to it is in terms of
getting business
focus on your existing customers first
and a lot of people may sound
feel like oh i've only got this one
customer i've got to go out and get some
more
and just to give a personal example
call it 18 months ago i built an app for
a realtor when she was out uh
showing houses to her customers one of
her customers
uh like the user experience on that
and he needed something she referred him
to me i built something for him he has
since referred me to more people so
again that all came from that one
project i got for
the realtor so it's as crucial as it is
to get new business and to how you sell
yourself to people
the best way to sell yourself to people
is by doing a really good job for the
people you're already working for
that's just the most important part yeah
i
agree with that i agree
and that's an excellent takeaway to end
our conference on
everybody you heard that right from luke
the best way to get new business
is to focus on your existing customers
dazzle them
they will send more business your way
definitely resonates with what i've
heard and
both phoebe and bolaji just agreed with
that so
uh i want to first of all i just want to
thank uh
phoebe luke bolaji thank you so much for
being on this panel
uh your cumulative decades
of freelancing experience are
extremely helpful and and we've learned
so much from your insights so thank you
for being here
for everybody who's still tuning in uh
it's been a four hour long conference
this entire conference will be on
youtube at this
i believe the same exact url as soon as
this ends it'll take a minute we're
going to edit out like the breaks and
everything
you'll have a nice three-ish three and a
half ish hour video you can watch
again you can watch it on double speed
if you want you can watch it on your
phone while you
go for a walk in a uh you know in a safe
manner
outside um we hope that there's been a
lot
of insight here uh thank you to
everybody who tweeted questions thank
you to everybody
in chat also i've been reading your uh
chat's been super positive i don't think
we've had any spam or anybody that's
needed to be banned or anything
because we put that member paywall up
sorry over
i mean it's like two dollars or five
dollars depending on where you are in
the world
so i really appreciate uh all the
supporting free code camp
uh that you know has basically offset
the costs associated with this
there's one very special person whom i
want to thank
uh and and uh not just
fizzle who's been incredibly helpful
and uh has been an amazing comc here um
and it's pretty late in india so i
really appreciate you staying up and
thank you to your family for tolerating
that
yeah it's 11 30 and uh i really enjoyed
this
conference uh quincy thanks for uh
partnering with us
and making this happen and thanks for
giving us an opportunity
to be a part of something like this
awesome everybody check out the dev blog
functionality on hash node i did it and
i wrote an article for how to get
started
uh just google dev blogs and you'll
learn all about it
um the the one person i super duper want
to thank
the person who's been doing all this av
and spent you know an entire
the equivalent of an entire day uh maybe
a day and a half
uh setting up these graphics and making
sure the slides all look good
and also uh just meeting with every
single speaker yesterday to do sound
check i just want to
give a very special thank you to matthew
potter
uh he's phenomenal if you're looking
speaking this is the freelancer panel if
anybody's looking for
somebody to do a conference like this on
their own youtube channel or twitch or
wherever
um he's your man uh and he's he's based
out of toronto
super helpful just just dm you on uh
twitter and i can i can put you in touch
with him uh i also i just want to go
through
and thank everybody who's been involved
everybody
and i'm just going to go through and uh
i've got the entire list of names i just
want to read through
thank everybody so first this is all
alphabetical order
alien learner interviewing dot io check
it out you can get interviewing practice
and she's got so many great articles on
free code games publication about
the nature of getting a job and the
numbers behind it she is
very data enthusiastic andrew brown with
exam pro.co
thank you andrew for your amazing aws
tutorials
if you want to get aws certified check
out the aws certified challenge hashtag
aws certified in freecodecamp's new
discord
chat we have a room just dedicated to
that so if you want to become a cloud
engineer you're in the right place
uh dawal shah with class central again
he eats sleeps and breathes online
courses he knows more about it than
anybody i know
he's he's one of the reasons free
cooking exists
i was doing something focused on moocs
early on and i was like man i can't
compete with
you know dahl shaw his his uh his site's
too
too comprehensive he's too good he cares
too much about online courses
so i just focused on coding right but uh
i want to thank the wall check out
classcentral.com
emma bostian check out the ladybugs
podcast
congratulations to her on landing her
new dream job she said the free cooking
was really helpful uh for her preparing
for this uh new job transition um
balaji right here on the call thank you
so much balaji
for joining us from nigeria
and of course laurence bradford
learn to code with me excellent podcast
she has 120
interviews with developers just in the
backlog and she's going to record some
new ones too
and she just got married congratulations
laurence she just got married during the
pandemic if you go to her instagram
you can see the pictures of her doing
this like
social distancing wedding it's really
profound
but congratulations to her and her
spouse um
uh colleen schnitler the work from home
uh supermom of three uh
amazing woman she uh has a video on
freecodecamp
youtube i don't know how to find it but
somebody can find and share it where she
basically walks through
a day in the life how she handles
everything how she works from home with
kids
now i don't think she has the benefit of
being able to get child care anymore
because of the
pandemic so i'm not sure how she's
handling it
but she's handling it and uh yeah it's
her little pomodoro
plus yoga very cool tip um luke
siciliano again freelancing
extraordinaire
a wellspring of knowledge thank you luke
for joining us
oh thank you um and be
be sure to check out his freelancing
course uh phoebe
thank you so much uh for joining us
phoebe vong vitel
fidel out in the uk now working
not as a freelancer but like doing
full-time work but
still has her freelancing chops and
knows a lot about the field
sid from code sandbox thank you for
joining us
uh hardcore dev knows a ton
uh has worked at you know off zero is
now working at code sandbox
uh a lot of engineering expertise there
uh
tech girl 1908 is her handle
angie jones check her out on twitter i
follow her i follow her for years she's
like just super
enthusiastic and and she brings a lot of
interesting
uh perspectives and shares a lot of
resources especially
around testing and of course the coder
coder
jessica chan one of the best instagrams
for programmers you should absolutely be
following her on instagram
that does it i just want to do another
thank you to the hashnote team
uh for everything they've done to
support this
and uh all their volunteerism preparing
you know they prepared backup questions
in case me and fuzzle didn't have any
good questions to ask we had like this
whole room that we didn't have to ever
reference really uh
and i want to thank the free code cam
team of course
uh i'm just gonna rattle off the names
very quickly since they've been super
duper helpful and
and i just want to recognize them uh tom
who just joined a few days ago right off
the top of my head
beau for running the youtube channel
which has grown dramatically
uh people are learning a lot from home
and we're thrilled to be part of that uh
process and we're thrilled to serve as a
learning resource uh of course abby has
been running our social media
thank you so much abby and and also
she's an editor for the publication
doing a whole lot of other stuff too
uh runs the free code game instagram yes
we do have an instagram it's really
fun check it out it's light-hearted it
won't stress your brain too much you can
decompress and watch other people work
and of course want to thank brigesh
and bengaluru keeping the servers up
despite the
double load this month i want to thank
um ahmed abdul sahib
over in turkey doing a lot of the design
work
helping us increase our donations by
actually slightly optimizing the donate
page
something that we should have done a
long time ago uh and
of course i want to thank um
i'm sorry i'm trying to think of
everybody else that works in freak camp
mia in china this is probably going to
be put into
billy billy which is the chinese youtube
so thank you
mia for everything you're doing to lead
the chinese community
and if i left anybody i apologize
i just want to say that it is with
profound
uh gratitude that you all have come
to watch this that uh you all are here
learning these insights from all these
people who've been there in the trenches
for years
if you are one of the many people who
have recently lost their jobs uh
my heart goes out to you don't despair
the remedy for despair is action
see what you can do focus on providing
for your family focus on keeping the
lights on the heat on
keeping food on the table absolutely
focus on keeping sane
once you've covered those bases and you
want to climb a little bit higher up the
the pyramid so to speak of of hierarchy
of need
you can actualize you can become a
developer
the opportunities are out there many of
the trends we've seen
toward automation toward remote work are
only going to be accelerated by this
pandemic uh
this like software development is
probably one of the fields that will be
least impacted
by the pandemic and all the economic
destruction
and all the lives lost uh so we can be
very grateful for that if nothing else
so uh one other person recognized
chris chris over in south korea uh
congratulations on your country's
extremely good
response hopefully it can be a template
for everybody else i know
like singapore and taiwan are following
close
so chris is doing a remarkable job
instructional design
awesome guy uh on the free code camp
team sorry i didn't want to admit him i
knew i had forgotten somebody
again thank you everybody for tuning in
i hope you've enjoyed lockdown conf
uh i'm going to be sending out a server
survey i'll just tweet it from my
with the hashtag lockdowncomp if anybody
wants to fill it out give us some ideas
for future panels future panelists um
we may do another one of these in the
future again thank you all
have a beautiful day uh for those of you
who are getting ready to go to sleep i
hope you get a good night rest wake up
tomorrow have lots of energy
cheers everybody happy coding thank you
bye bye
[Music]
oh